[Musique]
je me suis là
et bonjour à tous salut
pour cette cinquième ronde du coup de
Tata style
alors attends
un peu en double Samy
juste j'avais checker si ok c'est pour
ça que j'entendais en double yes donc du
coup donc bonjour à tous salut à tous
ceux qui qui arrivent sur le chat
donc on va vous montrer un petit peu les
apparements dans cette ronde aujourd'hui
les joueurs jouent à Amsterdam et non
pas à
vu ce qu'elle dit jusqu'à dit voilà
c'est pas facile à prononcer je vais
vous montrer un petit peu les
appartements de de cette ronde
donc
hop Matt shop donc vous avez ici karwana
avec les Blancs qui va affronter so
Wesley donc là c'est un derby ils ont
déjà joué ensemble je sais pas combien
de fois peut-être 20 ou 30 fois ça le
mien
oui
il va forcément jouer pour le gain
puisqu'il est toujours très bien préparé
avec les Blancs sauf on peut se douter
que cette attention va être très pleutre
comme à son habitude dans ce tournoi il
a déjà fait que des nuls pour l'instant
il va sûrement essayer de verrouiller le
jeu est un peu décevant dans sa partie
contre
contre rapport il avait un avantage
enfin il y avait une position il pouvait
essayer de presser un peu il a même pas
essayé donc il avait les Noirs certes
mais bon car c'est ne l'aurait jamais
jamais fait nul alors qu'elle a une
possibilité de pouvoir presser du coup
voir un peu ses ambitions dans le
tournoi c'est pas c'est pas si clair
donc
la jeune star indienne qui monte qui est
pour l'instant l'entraîneur rouge
tournoi qui joue contre Richard rapport
donc le rapport qui est qui est aussi un
peu décevant je trouve dans ce tournoi
qui montre pas grand chose surtout au
niveau des ouvertures il est souvent mal
en fait dans le début de partie donc on
va voir je pense que les deux joueurs
auront à cœur de se refaire avec cette
partie je pense qu'on peut avoir une
part spectaculaire parce que rapport
comme tu le dis il est sur courant
alternatif à moins capable du pire comme
du meilleur et mon cash il a commencé le
tournoi par deux défaites
l'hémorragie avec deux nulles ensuite
mais bon il a les blancs c'est le moment
ou jamais pour essayer un petit peu
d'enclencher son compteur de victoire
donc ça va être une partie je pense
intéressante
et ensuite on a donc parram contre vente
forest donc par un vent de Forest bon
c'est les deux joueurs qui à mon goût je
pense sont les les moins forts et moins
expérimenté
le tournage
à 2 ans il avait fait une énorme
surprise mais c'est quand même le numéro
enfin le dernier et l'autre droit et
ouais donc pour moi c'est c'est une
partie aussi où les deux joueurs ont à
coeur de battre l'autre en plus et de
gens qui jouent le gain à chaque fois
donc je pense qu'on peut aussi avoir une
belle partie entre nos deux joueurs
il a pas hésité à essayer de prendre des
risques avec les Noirs contre karwana je
crois que c'était la room 3 sur une
pétrole ou les sorties de nouveautés
finalement c'était mal passé pour lui
mais couleur en tout cas il envoie il a
beaucoup de nouvelles idées dans les
ouvertures
très créatif qui aime beaucoup qui aime
beaucoup
le fight d'ailleurs Mathieu Colette
m'avait dit que
matso de l'eau donc c'est lui qui a
remplacé du coup Douda en pied levé et
apparemment il s'est préparé qu'avec les
Noirs parce qu'il a pas eu le temps de
préparer les blancs du coup on imagine
qu'il a quand même préparé un petit peu
contre vent de Forest il est pas arrivé
le main dans les poches non plus mais ça
va te partir en tout cas intéressantes
ensuite on a 45 contre
donc 45 qui a perdu hier contre
avant-hier pardon c'était le repos hier
donc il a perdu avant-hier contre anis
je dirigeur d'une très très belle partie
donc Arsen aura à cœur clairement aussi
de se refaire il va vraiment
battre
donc qui a 18 ans qui est qui a été
champion de du monde de blitz
de rapides pardon en 2021 qui qui
progresse qu'elle progression en flèche
qui a 2720 quasiment
stuff il a gagné deux parties déjà donc
il est en tête avec
il est en tête
tu te rappelles justement il y a une
belle partie c'était au mois de décembre
avec les Blancs une grosse partie qu'on
raconte une Anglaise
et classique ils vont peut-être pas
forcément jouer à une ouverture mais ce
serait intéressant de comparer ouais bon
en tout cas favori clairement en plus il
a les blancs et en plus il vient de
perdre donc généralement vous voyez
jamais un champion du monde un jour
comme Carlsen perdre deux parties
d'affilée ça n'arrive jamais donc
Carlsen va essayer de
montrer un peu qu'il est de reprendre
cette partie en tout cas je pense que
c'est ce qui va essayer de faire
et d'ailleurs on a mauvais perdant donc
piqué dans son orgueil hier
Michael photo sur facebook pour la
journée de repos ils ont joué au foot
les joueurs c'est une tradition
défouler sur sur le terrain et on va
voir et d'ailleurs donc aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui nous rejoignent la ronde a lieu
au Stadium Johan Cruyff donc en hommage
au célèbre joueur de foot on va voir si
la porte bonheur à Carcès je sais que
c'est un gros fan de foot quand il aura
sûrement à cœur il doit gagner en fait
il a déjà pas trop le choix quasiment
parce que si il gagne pas ici il a un
point de retard là
ça commence à être un peu dur déjà au
niveau du classement bah il a un point
de retard déjà sur sur son adversaire du
jour donc en le battant bah il aura ça
donc serait déjà une belle opération de
gagner cette partie
donc on aura encore derrière du coup
près d'un mandat donc le tombeur de
jingleeren hier avec les Noirs donc par
exemple c'est mon chouchou depuis
toujours tu sais que il y a l'année
dernière j'avais parié avec Kevin Théry
on avait chacun un chouchou c'était le
mienda et donc du coup ça deuxième
participation à style et il aura les
blancs ici contre anus gris donc qui en
tête lui aussi avec abdos les deux
joueurs donc Agnès guéri qui vient de
battre aussi Carcen à la ronde 4 donc
une partie en tout cas avec deux des
leaders du tournoi c'est les deux gros
chocs à bout et à Prague contre guéri
clairement les deux styles les plus
intéressantes en tout cas sur le papier
ouais
[Musique]
et
je trouve
la partie du coup avec aronyan du coup
contre gamer donc à
bon bah c'est les gens ça fait ça fait
15 ans qu'il est qu'il est au top niveau
là il est sur une passe sur une phase un
petit peu descendante mais
je sais pas
1735 je crois
même 35 il a eu je crois donc il est à
-100 par rapport à son top mais non mais
il a fait une mauvaise Olympiades il a
perdu 20 points puis il avait mal joué
aussi au championnat de les États-Unis
enfin et mais aronia c'est un joueur qui
est toute sa vie a eu dans les 2780 quoi
donc
là capable sur une partie peut-être
faire une partie parfaite en fait donc
donc dans tout le cas
bon ça reste quand même un des favoris
aussi le tournoi capable de gagner donc
qui est vice champion du monde de Blitz
et qui a fait une super année 2022 aussi
qui qui passe les 2700 et là aussi en
l'an donc
la jeunesse qui joue contre
voilà donc la partie qui vont débuter
donc normalement d'ici deux minutes on
va vous mettre la vue avec avec les
caméras donc pour l'instant vous avez la
salle de jeux les joueurs qui sont pas
encore installés et encore deux minutes
avant le début de la ronde
et donc là on a changé de salle envoyé
on est plus du tout dans la salle de ta
style habituelle comme les Samy ils sont
dans le dans une salle du stade de foot
de Amsterdam
et
tout si j'ai bien compris a priori
ensuite il retourneront à wiscan je
crois c'est ça donc demain il retourne
enfin après la partie je sais pas il
retourneront ma caméra qui a sauté et
du coup
ma caméra soit
salut à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
merci pour vos messages n'hésitez pas à
se poser des questions et le changement
de salle justement pour répondre à
Arnaud je sais pas exactement alors à
mon avis l'idée c'est de promouvoir un
petit peu les échecs dans une autre
ville ce que dit c'est vraiment tout
petit et donc l'idée Amsterdam et de
fêter un peu les échecs là-bas je pense
que c'est la raison principale
oui c'est ça
donc après c'est la première année qui
font ça je crois que avant ça il
changeait pas de salle comme ça en cours
en cours de tournoi donc on va voir en
tout cas mais pourquoi pas moi je trouve
ça elle est super jolie on voit les
spectateurs aussi à côté à ma caméra qui
fait que de sauter je vais voir si je
peux vous mettre une autre
pourquoi Maxime il joue pas et ce qui
n'est pas qualifié alors ce temps-là il
est pas sur qualification il est sur
invitation il y a que chaque année le
vainqueur du Challenger qui gagne son
ticket pour le Master de l'année d'après
et donc les invitations après les
joueurs peuvent être invités la refuser
potentiellement ça peut-être été le cas
avant de fil rouge à l'an dernier et
pour ce qui est le Maxime je sais que
c'est un temps qui va aussi pas trop par
le passé là pas eu de très bonne
performances il aime pas du tout le
climat là-bas
c'est très menteur il a pas des bons
souvenirs et donc plutôt que de faire un
tournoi qui va réussit pas ou selon il
perd de points à l'eau je pense qu'il a
préféré faire l'impasse et se concentrer
sur des futurs objectifs et tournoi
qualificatif pour les candidats
donc maxime a priori bon moi ce que je
sais c'est qu'il n'a pas été invité et
de toute façon il ne voulait pas y aller
donc c'est clair mais
l'an dernier il avait joué ou c'était il
y a deux ans justement je me souviens il
avait joué je crois hein
Mathieu on le retrouvera
plus tard dans le tournoi aujourd'hui il
y a grève et du coup ça peut-il va pas à
l'école faut s'en occuper du coup pas de
Mathieu pas de Cornetto cet après-midi
et il est prévu pour revenir je sais
plus exactement à quel ronde mais un
petit peu plus tard
yes alors attends je vais vous mettre
donc
il fait une Anglaise un petit peu comme
une comme il avait joué lors du match du
championnat en rapide là
qui avait
sorti plusieurs sacrifices il me semble
en fait c'était une
si tu veux une Sicilienne inversée
hérisson où il avait joué un G4 avec les
Blancs thématiques dans l'hérisson avec
les noirs
et
donc c'est un truc à utiliser beaucoup
Fischer à l'époque d'ailleurs j'ai 5
donc il a fait G4 qui était un peu
surprenant dans cette position là et qui
en fait un GSM G4 et puis Ontario quand
j'ai 6 et il y avait eu des sacrifices
avec GSM ça avait été assez monstrueux
avec la caméra
pour la question d'Arnaud pour le public
je sais pas trop s'il y a du bruit il
faut savoir aussi que en plus donc du
Master de challengers il y a plein
d'Open qui joue parallèlement
après je sais pas si les open pour le
coup ça a été déplacé aussi ou pas
d'ailleurs c'est une bonne question
non après c'est possible que non je
ouais en fait là je pense qu'il s'est
passé c'est que comme tu me dis que les
challengers par exemple et ben ça joue
pas aujourd'hui
donc du coup ils vont rattraper le
tournoi du coup à partir de demain et
aujourd'hui du coup on a cette salle là
pour pour le Master et l'Open je sais
pas si si ça change pour eux j'imagine
peut-être pas tu vois
pas trop déloger un tournoi avec
plusieurs centaines de joueurs c'est
difficile donc quand on a 10 qui sont
invités pourquoi pas mais quand on a
plus que ça ça devient plus difficile
l'éclairage c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne remarque de petits pouce sur deux
bois assez particulier ça donne un côté
un peu tamisé ouais ça a l'air sympa je
trouve
j'aime bien
j'aime bien je trouve ça cool
pas que tu puisses agrandir les avatars
des joueurs
au revoir
je vais essayer de refaire un peu
effectivement
tout était tout seul aujourd'hui donc
j'ai un peu de peine pour lui je suis
venu traiter un enfant en commentaire
c'est gentil de ta part d'ailleurs je
t'ai pas remercié avec plaisir
depuis le début on a eu on a eu Kevin
thérieux on a eu Mathieu Cornette et
maintenant on a on a Sami Robin donc
toujours de plus en plus fort vous voyez
le niveau
[Rires]
aussi Fab qui va passer
demain ça revient sur sur Kevin Tarrieux
bon je crois 3 jours et puis après on
voit après on aura le repos puis on aura
Fab juste après
après j'ai pas encore parlé dans la
vitesse surprise
vous allez voir plein de vous allez voir
des nouvelles têtes aussi du coup pas
mal de nouvelles têtes
qui marche peut-être en deux autres
[Musique]
il y aura au moins trois personnes
et pour l'ouverture c'est une Anglaise
Benoît une Anglaise et la réponse de
Abdou satarov c'est parce qu'il a choisi
la plus
considérée peut-être comme la
plus solide mais la plus joué
neutraliser
beaucoup beaucoup de choses sont
possibles ici là on va avoir
probablement des quatre je pars Carlson
et ça c'est les lignes qui sont qui sont
hyper connues en niveau qui sont ultra
jouets après généralement dans
l'anglaise on joue souvent des systèmes
avec G6 qui n'a pas été le cas ici et
aussi des cinq qui était possible à la
place de 5
[Musique]
qui sera à la Régie à la technique et
accompagner de
différents invités
ça fait ça fait long
couverture surtout on va tourner un
petit peu
alors on va le voir un petit peu
qu'est-ce qui vous voulez aller voir
peut-être l'autre partie qui était
chaude peut-être présente Google
[Musique]
ça c'est connu pour l'instant tout ça je
pense partout tout le monde donc pour
l'instant pas de surprise on va un petit
peu
comment comment on continue
ça joue vite en tout cas c'est le début
Italian normal avec A6 et 6 donc on
avait vu avec Mathieu plusieurs idées à
6 ou à 5 deux coups sont possibles avec
les noirs et les blancs aussi à 4 pour
je fous à deux pardon je peux expliquer
en général on le joue à 6 dans le but
c'est que des fois il y a des cavaliers
A4 avec les Blancs pour les manger la
perte de fou comme ça on a une case de
ça marche dans les deux sens et les
blancs les noirs on a une case de replis
pour nos faux respectifs
et du coup à 4 c'est pour mettre le fond
à deux en quatre cavaliers à 5 et donc
faut aussi on a vu hier enfin c'est pas
la même partie parce que souvent le
cavalier va il vend des deux avec ces
trois du coup le cavalence de mettre une
pièce en dessin qu'un jour
donc
on va un peu comment il va jouer ici
Prague en tout cas faut prendre aussi je
pense sur pas du tout d'actualité vu que
le but c'est qu'elle est dans une maison
des cinq donc si on fait [ __ ] en puis
on prend on aura du mal à mettre un
cavalier en dessin donc intéressant
mais là on reprend vers le centre les
pions doublés ils sont mauvais plutôt
quand ils sont isolés quand ils sont pas
de pions à côté d'eux là ça reste si à
cet échange une petite masse compacte de
pions au centre qui se protège les uns
les autres ça ouvrirait aussi la colonne
F pour la tour après un petit roc donc
voilà faut se méfier de quand on dit
puis on oublie c'est automatiquement
mauvais parfois on peut avoir ce mauvais
réflexe quand on débute c'est pas
toujours le cas il y a pas mal
d'exception et ici ce serait tout à fait
ok pour les noirs
et au passage salut à Hugo et bienvenue
aussi Auchan
salut à tous salut à tous ceux qui
arrivent sur le chat donc si vous êtes
des questions ou des parties que vous
voulez voir
surtout n'hésitez pas pardon à vous
demander on essaiera de de vous éclairer
au maximum alors sur un tour des stades
on va aller voir irigazi Ding donc
pareil c'est c'est italienne avec C3 du
coup cette fois-ci donc petit rock
il y a pas eu de A6 ni à 5 pour
l'instant chez les Noirs il y a
plusieurs moyennes manière de jouer ici
avec les Blancs que j'ai une B4 A4 une
expansion classique
chez les Blancs qui qui permet de
pouvoir se prendre l'espace à l'aide
d'âme et cette information
qui était aussi possible
on a vu plein d'idées hier avec Mathieu
c'était H6 info H4 G5 qui est possible
ici avec foug3 il y a plein d'idées
différentes aussi
longtemps
que ça peut être très difficile et très
dangereux à jouer mais bon les joueurs
savent ce qu'ils font ils sont préparés
très très bien
quand tu as un cavalier blanc peut
atteindre la caser des 5 là c'est pas le
cas
mais après l'idée pour la toux à de
taper sur ce cavalier mais on verra si
on a
un développement un petit peu
spectaculaire on espère
c'est parti donc
c'est un bon concept pollution pour pour
poser une question en fait au foot 15
blanche moi ce que tu veux aller et du
coup le fou va du coup en H4 donc là on
va voir si on va avoir G5 de jouets moi
je pense que oui
je pense que le 5 va être le coup ici je
sens que ça a été joué
fou G3 et là on avait vu des parties
enfin des propositions hier avec Mathieu
existait à cette position pour
jean-baptage 5
qui permet aussi peut-être fou aussi
plus tard
donc
avoir
généralement sur A5 on fait à 4 pour
avoir la case B5
généralement c'est c'est le coup un peu
thématique qu'on va faire ici et
d'ailleurs souvent la prochaine qui
existe c'est genre du A4 et surfaut 6
vous gardez regardez ce foodcast blanche
pour pas échanger et du coup ben le fait
de jouer à 5 ben ça empêche cavaler à 5
et du coup il y a plus ce fou qui est
enfermé quoi donc
il va faire la manœuvre sûrement
annoncée par Yuma le petit prince du
coup trois fêtes
standard avec un gars qui peut venir en
E3 Elise et belle case D5 F5 et du coup
vous aussi c'est fou B5
peut-être ici une une possibilité
j'avais vu pas mal de parties de Ding en
fait il aimait bien faire
une fois qu'il est 5 faire des dames
sur cette belle diagonale
et juste pour expliquer cette idée de
cavalier des deux cavalier F1 c'est par
rapport au développement classique comme
ça notre cavalier en C3 généralement
d'habitude et là la case est prise par
le pion
du coup vous trouvez un autre moyen
d'activer notre cavalier en B1 qui est
pour l'instant au bercail et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on va passer par cette
manœuvre D2 puis on est fin puis on E3
pour visiter un petit peu le centre
ouais
donc souvent on met la valeur G3 mais là
il y a un fou du coup c'est plutôt
le travail mais après son passé par A3
C2 aussi c'est on l'a déjà vu ça dans on
l'a vu dans quelle partie le tournoi on
a vu je me suis un peu un cavalier A3
c'est de pour venir en E3 ce qui est
important de comprendre c'est que dans
ces Italiens souvent il y a une grosse
lutte pour le centre et donc souvent
c'est d'un côté les blancs ils jouent
pour essayer de pousser des quatre et
les noirs pour essayer de pousser des
cinq au centre et donc leur pièce elle a
conservir à préparer et anticiper c'est
de pousser pour qu'elles arrivent dans
de bonnes conditions
des deux côtés
c'est quand même un des enjeux des
principaux enjeux ici
donc position en septembre on avait eu
plein de parties qui qui ressemblent à
ça dans le tournoi on a vu pas mal de
choses
c'est quoi d'autres surprises alors
caroann Asos c'est une écossaise
avec un petit four à 3 on va voir un
petit peu donc une écossaise à cavalier
F6 5 dameset donc ça c'est hyper
classique
X6 B3 donc B3 c'est c'était le coup de
casse-parf
G6 c'est fou à 3 ok donc souvent le coup
c'était souvent G3 ici donc le fond en
G2 et
ça doit exister
là j'ai plus en tête ces idées là mais
on peut imaginer souvent des comme ça ça
marche pas parce que vous voyez qu'ici
il y a un clouage sur sur la dame donc
je peux pas manger le cavalier en fait
non je perdrais madame par contre si je
dame aussi en faisant prise en DS5
j'attaque madame aussi du coup pour
savoir
non mais c'est juste pour être sûr
je mange là
pas de problème
donc pièce de plus donc du coup c'est
pas possible donc peut-être imaginer
comme D6 ici pour les noirs qui
menacerait d'un point de 5 d'ailleurs
dans ce genre de position même sans X3
parce que le but c'est de mettre de la
pression sur le vis-à-vis au centre donc
ça peut paraître le coup le plus logique
d'ici ici d'ailleurs c'est en D6 puis on
prend
on risque d'avoir un
un pion prend je pense
je sais pas un expert étonnant que sans
réfléchisse était sûr que faut à trois
fais voir si tu vois
c'est un couple sérieux mais pas du tout
dans
qui réfléchit ici quelle est sa
meilleure option après c'est déjà à haut
niveau l'écossaise c'est pas une
ouverture qui est beaucoup joué les gens
se connaissent très très bien du coup il
se permet de pouvoir varier et changer
un petit peu
leur variante contre certains joueurs et
mais du coup certains joueurs ont des
petites préparations contre de leur
spécifiques et du coup faut
accroissement une idée que Carla avait
jamais sorti quand on dit de relever ce
soit avec les Blancs pour pouvoir les
placer donc voilà so il doit connaître X
à 3 il absorbe déjà vu mais là je pense
qu'il est en train d'essayer de se
rappeler de ces variantes
pour voir un petit peu comment comment
ça marche quoi parce que je pense pas
que tu puisses surprendre un sauter au
bout du coup sur une négociation
[Musique]
cette ligne n'est peut-être pas
forcément fois 3 donc je pense
je connaissais pas
non mais Kevin joue là je voulais que ça
après je sais pas si c'est là à la fois
ça
ok ça marche
peut-être intéressant du coup
comme quoi peut-être que notre ami van
forest aurait
reparti à celle assez marrante
alors on va regarder on va regarder
donc ça commence comme ça
donc voilà donc gambidame accepter de la
part de bonne forest avec E4 alors
généralement on dit que 3 c'est le
principal ici pour lutter pour le centre
et que des fois le 4 et 20 c'est pas
forcément le mieux parce que sans qu'il
est possible et du coup les noirs
peuvent réussir à lutter contre le
centre la meilleure vente c'est E31
généralement après j'imagine que McDo
slow ici il a sûrement une idée donc
elle a trois fou BK
donc là bon moi je connais pas grand
chose à ça je vais voir si j'ai une
petite base pour vous aiguiller un petit
peu parce que cavaler C3
quasiment de la part de Forest ça a été
joué très peu de fois avec les Noirs ici
eux prend des cartes reste le lavarente
principale avec le premier cas de
cavaler prendre des quatre et on sort
les pièces donc
peut être sympa
de cette petit roc et donc il y a plein
de parties comme ça qui ont été jouées
et du coup cavalier F6 c'est une c'est
une qui est assez rare j'ai l'impression
il laisse l'option E5 mais il peut
manger le pion en 4 ça peut être du troc
qui se passe sur cavalier prend un
quatre
échec qui peut être compliqué
qui attaque le fou qui fait échec et sur
un cavalier C6 pour défendre le fou il y
aura qu'elle va les princesses après il
faut calculer parce que je peux prendre
ici intermédiaire par exemple
en fait ouais mais j'ai pas vu
tu prends échec et que je mange là
faut voir parce que si tu prends le
cavalier ici je prends sur échec et tu
as tout en prise tu mets le foot devant
je prends cavalier et je refais
d'ailleurs
le coup
pour clouer et j'empêche aussi le
cavalier prendre des vitres
et après voir ce qui se passe en fait il
faut penser 4 elle a pas mal ouais bon
du coup ça a pas été joué c'est
compliqué
donc c'est marrant parce que Max the
slow ici il a l'impression d'être
vraiment bien préparé parce qu'il joue
hyper vite
un jeu un truc hyper hyper rare donc
c'est ça a été joué est-ce que tu peux
essayer de nous expliquer la nuance
pourquoi il a fait A3 puis A4 et pas à 4
directement justement on peut se poser
la question
A4 ici aurait pu être possible
mais du coup pardon je dis certainement
il préfère que le fou sont à 5 vis avec
la tour peut-être après mais c'est pas
si il y a un visa qui est possible ici
mais aussi peut-être que le fou a plus
de perspectives sur cette diagonale là
et quand Jean A3 en premier et ben on va
virer le fou en fait sur cette case à 5
et du coup j'ai peut-être moins de
perspectives depuis celle-là que depuis
celle-là déjà moins une case possible
donc A3 on va mettre le fou sur une
mauvaise case puis après jouer à 4 pour
pour casser
c'est ça doit être l'idée je pense
et après A4 qui a eu ces 5 donc il veut
tout casser et donc du coup
à manger c'est 5 il crois pas du tout
qui mange tous les pions donc là après
oui quand on voit la jauge on voit qu'il
y a un balaçage pour pour les blancs
mais on en a parlé hier encore
avant-hier avec Mathieu en fait l'idée
c'est que des fois on peut jouer des
préparations qui sont
pas forcément très correct mais où les
blancs doivent trouver que des coups
précis et dans cette position mais ce
qui se passe c'est que les Blancs ont
déjà un pion de plus et il y a un autre
pion en prix etc mais les Noirs ont
vraiment une avance de logement vous
voyez que les pièces blanches sont tout
à la maison
et du coup en pratique si par rame
connaît pas sa ligne précisément de gros
problèmes
sur sur le roi
par exemple donc du coup
du coup vraiment
il y a aussi l'effet surprise et l'effet
de le fait de de
jouer une préparation ou la réponse
l'adversaire est vraiment difficile à
trouver on en a parlé l'autre jour donc
du coup même si la courbe non c'est un
interventage blanc on peut imaginer que
que parrain va pas jouer
comme l'ordinateur pour un truc la
partie donc à mon avis il va faire un
précision et du coup à ce moment-là fin
de Forest dans sa préparation pourra
revenir sur l'égalité voir peut-être
plus en tout cas ça c'est ce qui espère
peut-être
de l'ordinateur et l'aspect pratique
ouais c'est ça on n'est pas des
ordinateurs même les gens à 2700 ou 2800
ils peuvent pas jouer comme l'ordinateur
surtout dans certaines types de position
donc je pense que ici on voit d'ailleurs
déjà il y a un problème malgré tout sur
le cavalier E5 qui a attaqué et qui a
pas de case
[Musique]
et moi je trouve que l'effet de surprise
en tout cas en pratique c'est très très
dur et j'aime bien la position de one
forest je trouve que c'est une position
qui est compliquée et lui il sait ce
qu'il faut faire donc du coup c'est ça
l'avantage cette position quand on a une
pollution ou tout
par un peu en cacahuète mais que toi et
ben tu sais où placer tes pièces tu sais
quel est ton plan tu sais quels sont les
bons coups mauvais coups de l'adversaire
aussi c'est pas mal alors quant à cette
position avec les blancs mais que tu
sais pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est c'est
difficile quand tu découvres la position
c'est compliqué c'est déjà là on en fait
quoi encore une fois F4 bah il y a
cavalier pendant 4 au minimum
ici il faut F4 et 7 mais en pratique bah
ok il faut calculer parce que ça m'a pas
l'air si simple que ça ou peut-être
qu'on a du cahier G6
un fouet F4 fou prend et un cavalier
bouge du style vous voyez je fais ça
j'attaque là
et que si tu manges mon four en F4 chez
un F4 après je peux venir en dessin donc
ça a l'air de marcher peut-être que
c'est du coup c'est pas le bon coup la
cabane à 50 intéressants aussi qui va
diminuer ce défenseur
en tout cas c'est ça a pas l'air simple
en pratique franchement
ça a pas que ça en pratique alors
pourquoi la mec est pas comme ça je
pense que tu as peut-être Dame des 6
qui permettait de venir
attaquer la dame E7 et sur d'un prank
puis on prend etc
donc je pense que dame 8 en plus d'un V8
il joue tempo bon c'est un peu un coup
d'ordi quoi
donc donc du coup
pardon c'est quoi la différence du coup
entre la maison
de moins etc et puis là je vais faire un
temps quoi donc
du coup c'est une explication très
logique et on nous dit effectivement la
ligne de l'ordi alors on peut regarder
un c'est apparemment de sacrifier une
pièce on peut jouer intéressant
vous prend ces trois donc on enlève
notre fou qui a attaquer en prenant une
pièce sur échec et derrière on mange le
cavalier
et là non c'est pas français 4 c'est
Dame des quatre
tu veux défendre là il y a tes câlin et
tu veux dire bon bah j'ai un rouleau
compresseur de pion
je voudrais pouvoir manger un pion ou
alors à installer un bouquin Popi
cavalier en 5 mais sans ça je pense
qu'il va avoir c'est 6 et je vais devoir
manger
et ça me paraît ouf d'être préparé
jusque là
dans une ligne qui qui a été très très
peu joué
donc ok avoir en tout cas une partie qui
va être sympa je pense à suivre Samia
[Musique]
alors on n'a pas vu des parties on n'est
pas allé voir encore Aronian qui qui bon
un Italien un peu un peu standard il y a
avec le fou au 7 du coup notre troisième
donc là il y a plein d'idées plus tard
avec les Noirs un pendus avec du Cabal
et B8 cavaler des sets
la vraie heure avec un bébé
à l'époque je connaissais un peu de
théorique je veux 5 avec les Noirs j'ai
déjà joué des choses comme ça c'était un
des rares trucs
depuis la théorie a bien évolué tu
imagines
et puis après tu fais juste ce que j'ai
7 et bien c'est quasiment une fille d'or
en fait
c'est simple
un peu plus d'espace pour les Noirs mais
c'est structure un peu un peu plus donc
cette position qu'on peut atteindre à
partir de l'espagnol mais aussi à partir
de sicilienne un peu dans cette position
il y a une ligne qui transpose avec fou
B5 échec
c'est avec des six
et comme ça et des cinq c'est une grande
Feld
la nouvelle c'est
juste pour expliquer un peu dans les
stands on va avoir une position
variante
au niveau du centre et où est noir on
peut toujours jouer à l'endroit elle est
blond plutôt à l'aile d'arme alors que
la grenade avec des seins ça réagit
immédiatement au centre ça crée un
conflit sur les pions centraux et donc
ça a pas du tout la même physionomie
souvent ça a pas mal d'échanges et
d'ailleurs je crois que dans la partie
je crois que les dames je sais pas j'ai
pas vu encore
majorité à l'eldame donc bon des
productions qui sont assez égales j'ai
l'impression pour l'instant et on va
voir un petit peu comment comment ça
continue
ce genre de finale
gros joueur de graines
il y a toujours ce problème de cavaliers
à 5 à résoudre parfois qui est un petit
peu mal placé le pion B qui peut être un
peu faible combien la bonne place pour
le footclasse blanche elle est énorme
des petits soucis à régler et après
normalement s'ils sont précises arrivent
à égaliser quoi
alors souvent en fait les idées c'est de
jouer avec vous aussi store C8 pièces en
C4 et une fois si jamais j'arrive à
jouer faut aussi se tourner vite et
peut-être un fou C4 plus tard je
pourrais même commencer à pousser des
pions avec B5 et essayer de faire voilà
mon de contraint mais bon après c'est
pas si simple que ça mais c'est une idée
qu'on peut avoir ici dans la grande fête
avec les noirs
donc mais cette position pour l'instant
elle est assez
égal c'est une position qui enfin c'est
une partie en tout cas qui ne
m'intéresse pas plus que ça comparé à
d'autres qu'on a pu voir jusque là
donc il y a eu le cavalier H7 que je
t'avais dit ok on s'est arrêté à Tours
donc souvent pour jouer en fait H5 et
lancer la sauce sur le roi noir donc
Gabriel de rouage fuite F5 qui est aussi
possible donc position assez
intéressante en tout cas
donc
des cartes donc ça c'est assez logique
souvent donc on dit aux échecs
affaiblissement à l'aile réaction au
centre donc là on a faibli sur le roi à
l'aile donc la réaction logique des
blancs c'est centrale avec des 4 donc
pour l'instant on voit que il est pas
défendu que une fois et deux fois tandis
que les noirs peuvent manger une fois
deux fois et trois fois donc donc du
coup là ici les blancs sacrifié un pion
pour ouvrir la position donc sur pion
prend en D4 ça mille je pense qu'on peut
imaginer peut-être une idée à base de E5
plus tard donc je sais pas à quel moment
on peut le faire mais que les blancs
vont vouloir essayer d'avoir la position
que le roi soit ouvert pour pour tout
casser donc à ce que je mange en D4 en
premier du pion ou du cavalier ou est-ce
que je joue directement le 5
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien le 5 parce que ça ouvre
tout et puis ça me laisse aussi des fois
la diagonale aussi ouverte
blanche des cases pour un cavalier en 4
et puis aussi ouvrir un peu les cases
noires pour mon fous mon cavalier
donc un sacrifice thématique dans cette
position des câbles d'ailleurs ça a mis
une des positions que tu as commenté
dans dans le livre que tu as écrit avec
avec des stream il y a une partie qui
ressemble un petit peu un petit peu à ça
effectivement mais il a pas pris
à trois résultats donc ça va être
intéressant
et il me semble alors c'est pas qu'un
commentaire
la partie qui va gagner contre goûter
dans la première ronde avec les Noirs
Ding ça ressemblait pas un peu à ça
ça me parle un peu il avait poussé son
pion gênant
je sais plus exactement mais je crois
que c'était je crois que tu as raison je
crois que tu as raison il avait joué
d'ailleurs un G5
[Musique]
ok donc avaler H4 je prends des 4 et
tourbé un ouf alors tomber
alors comment vous explique ça
comment vous explique le cou qui vient
de Gazi donc en plus qui est réglé tout
tempo qui a 1h42 à la pendule exactement
je vais trop bien alors qu'on vient de
sacrifier un pion au centre essayer
d'ouvrir qu'on joue complètement de
l'autre côté sur l'aile roi et rejoindre
un coup de tour sur une colonne fermée
derrière un pion
alors soit il a rippait soit non une des
idées que je vois ça peut être que
surprise prix peut-être plus tard il y
aura des idées avec tour B5 qui pourra
venir attaquer
le roi noir j'imagine une idée comme ça
sauve donc pour immobiliser le fond
aussi vite voilà
quand on voit ça c'est logique par
contre du coup les noirs sont pas forcés
pour l'instant de te manger ici donc
peut-être que du coup avec son idée là
et bien il veut aller manger des quatre
et se dire que le jour il mangera il y
aura son idée là donc peut-être sur
cavaler B3 et manger des cartes mais ça
m'a l'air un peu un peu bizarre c'est
pas ça
avec les Noirs tu vas devoir me manger
en ces trois à un moment donné quoi
parce que ouais parce que là il est
quand même vachement commit avec le 5G4
donc du coup tu peux pas trop trop
chaud vous voyez bon là c'est cloué et
puis même si tu le préparer
le roi noir sera complètement ouvert
c'est trop dur et donc pour continuer
l'attaque avec les noirs
on peut espérer peut-être du cavalier 5
peut-être tout revête attaquer le pion
le pion en 4
évidemment ouais je pense que c'est une
nouveauté à vérifier mais
comment réagir à cette idée
nous a dit je veux un message comme quoi
apparemment c'était chaud sur la partie
de guéri peut-être on peut acheter un
œil après on reviendra à carcennes quand
même qu'on a pas beaucoup vu
alors Guiri
donc
Guiri qui vient de jouer
cavalier des quatre alors l'ouverture
c'était quoi déjà avec cette télé
ouais bon pour ils sont polissons assez
solide les noirs
partir sur un grand rock ici donc ça va
être sûrement du petit roc et à terme du
coup non mais on peut pas
pour l'instant mon Prague aussi un
Prague qui vient de battre Ding
pas mal de temps dessus on y reviendra
après on va d'abord jeter un oeil à 15h
vous avez vu que le début alors Karlsen
du coup donc on s'est arrêté 5 il a pas
le D4 bien tranquille et 5 donc standard
donc là du coup c'est un petit peu tu
vois si on inverse la position c'est un
peu comme si les Blancs avaient joué de
marozzi tu vois
donc en fait si tu voulais la l'anglaise
avec les avec les Blancs c'est un peu
une Sicilienne si vous voulez sicilienne
avec un temps de plus et après c'est pas
pareil exactement mais du coup comme à
jouer ici à Abdou et ben du coup on a
une on a une
on a une sorte de sicilienne avec un
temps d'avance donc faux 7 et là il
rejoue B5 c'est un marrant donc le fou
depuis fou S5
donc là du coup il veut
cavaler prend E5 et des problèmes aussi
sur sur la diagonale donc
est-ce qu'on va avoir ici un petit coup
comme le 4 5
où est-ce que c'est
je sais pas si c'est bon non il y a pas
du français 6 je pense c'est plutôt
ouais
une position justement où il veut jouer
vraiment d'ailleurs très stratégique et
peut-être contre la structure de pion
donc 4 je sais pas si on fait caille
d'abord
c'est pas forcément très très bon parce
que vraiment
endommagé dans ma cadre qui avait le
processus mais dans l'idée j'aurais
voulu bloquer un peu le pion des deux tu
vois c'est pour ça
clairement
D8 empêcher un peu
d'espace pour les Noirs donc je sais pas
trop
position un peu déséquilibré
créer un groupe pion arrière en deux et
ici pour répondre à la question de spool
shenky il y a pas forcément de mauvais
fou ici enfin le fond noir effectivement
des blancs des blancs peut être mauvais
typiquement après ce qu'on vient de voir
mais si les blancs à un moyen joue des
cartes ou quoi la position pourrait
complètement s'ouvrir et s'il y a plus
de centres du tout que ça éclate là il y
aura plus de mauvais fou puisque toute
façon les lignes sont les diagonales
sont ouvertes ça va vraiment dépendre
justement du cheval d'abdos dans les
prochains cours
[Musique]
pour montrer quand même effectivement
que sur dame Provence
on va manger ceci et on va griller la
tour à la fin
donc ça va pas pour les noirs
alors que alors que dans la Sicilienne
normale ça c'est hyper typique et encore
une fois les blancs plus dans leur
pseudo sicilienne donc ça montre que
ce qu'on peut faire d'habitude n'est pas
forcément valable dans ces positions là
ok alors j'ai vu qu'il s'est passé des
choses dans la partie de carwana so
tu vois donc c'est la
c'est l'écossaise
avant qu'on regarde la position
donc il a une demi-heure en avance il a
toujours été tempo donc il est en train
de nous faire ça spécial car on a cette
tête le joueur qui nous a sorti en tout
cas le joueur moderne et prépa le plus
monstrueux je me suis notamment celle
contre Maxime aux candidat tu te
souviens
c'est vraiment le joueur on a
l'impression qu'il est capable de
de connaître une partie jusqu'au bout
par coeur sur toutes les lignes malgré
des dizaines de tactiques dans chaque
variante donc on va voir si ça
si c'est plus répétitif avec saut et la
victime ici en tout cas la position a
l'air très chaud alors comment ils ont
sont arrivés
on avait dit que c'était le coup qui
était le plus joué par rapport à notre
base de données et du coup B2 a été joué
donc l'idée c'est qu'il voulait on va
dire mal placé ce cavalier ça paraît pas
c'est instinctif puisque le cavalier au
moins il est plus attaqué Cloé
clairement puis là en plus il menace une
petite découverte avec avec ici fou B2
donc ça force un petit peu fou G7 et
maintenant à 3
c'est la seule case qu'il est le pion il
est cloué
je te recharge tu es obligé d'y
retourner mais en fait du coup il a
gagné un petit temps dans la partie il a
gagné à trois
gratuites parce qu'en fait c'est comme
si regarder c'est marrant ce qu'il a
fait c'est comme ce qu'il avait joué
G7 A3
c'était encore à lui de jouer en fait
parce que là son heure de jouer dans
cette position tombée comme ça et du
coup avec X à 3 cavalier B4 je reviens
là et je te chasse donc en fait
alors des fois le coup à trois c'est un
coup qui est très très bien dans ces
positions mais des fois ça peut aussi
être un problème alors moi je suis un
joueur de d'écossaise et je sais que ce
petit pion B3 des fois ça peut être une
cible une faiblesse et on n'a pas
forcément envie de pousser des pions des
fois donc avoir un petit peu OK
petit rock et grand rock donc
défend le pion faible en B3
et donc le grand et derrière il a envoyé
le pion h quand
il faut défendre ce petit pion quand
même cavalier B6 et ici H4 donc donc H4
D5 réaction au centre et H5 donc là
c'est une partie qui commence à partir
dans tous les sens
partie très compliquée et il peut se
passer de tout
on peut voir des Français 4 qui va qui
va arriver et sur des Français 4 on a on
sait pas trop quoi faire parce que sur
cavalier français 4 par exemple
ben ouais on a l'impression que le roi
blanc il va il va souffrir
à quatre mais elle avait l'air pas mal
disparaître c'est terminé pour le moment
et tout enfin c'est là si je pouvais
et bon ça a l'air perdu donc c'est pas
ce qui va se passer bienvenue tout le
monde à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent au
passage on a des parties intéressantes
aujourd'hui
objectif de gagner en finissant avec
deux heures non
ok
je suis monté à 1h peut-être 1h45 dans
50 et j'ai gagné la partie
de l'avoir fait parce que c'était pas
très correct
c'est parti
c'était ma jeunesse voilà pas bien
c'est ça donc là on voit quand même
qu'il y a un petit clouage vous voyez
sur la diagonale qui fait que du coup
les normes peuvent pas continuer à
manger les pions parce qu'il perdraient
des pièces après il faut calculer parce
que même ça ça fait un petit peu peur
imaginons un petit pion prend juste ton
imaginant que si je fais ça avec échec
échec bon ça peut faire un peu peur
malgré tout ce calcul est un petit peu
quand même mais a priori il y a pas
grand chose je me mets des lames devant
donc ça va mais faut être sûr quand même
mais pour l'instant ça marche prend
c'est pas une grosse menace parce que
après la mâche ça tu aurais roi fuite en
fait et rien de plus pour l'instant mais
on peut juste
d'attaque en fait quand
ce fouet là confirme keto a priori on
peut pas le déloger on va pas du tout
avoir de réelles choses de maths donc il
faut le but des blancs ça va être
forcément d'une façon de réussir
peut-être pourquoi pas ouvrir la grande
diagonale pour que le défenseur en G7
disparaisse et qu'on puisse vraiment
essayer de mater de manière concrète
sinon en fait on fait juste un échec en
achète mais c'est juste du vent
mais après faut voir parce que après
dommage 7 il joue un coup dommage 7 rois
F6 et menacer des petits des petits
maths en G8 surtout que
je vais faire deux coups pour que vous
compreniez un peu de quoi on parle qu'un
petit cavalle 4 qui peut être pas mal
et FC etc et si jamais on joue un fou
qu'on E5 il y a un beau petit mat en
deux Sami je te laisse
prendre par le fou mais il y a tout
reprend qui fait mat parce que du coup
le fou contrôle la case de fuite du roi
donc en fait donc il y a quand même pas
mal de motifs qui sont intéressants
et donc avoir un peu comment ça se passe
mais en tout cas car voilà qui joue à
tempo je suis assez d'accord avec quoi
que c'est un Anonymous ici moi
visuellement je connais pas la position
où je prends les Noirs tous les jours
enfin je sais pas c'est une grosse prépa
de noir ça fait plus peur quand même
pour moi du côté blanc que du côté noir
parce que encore une fois on a ce
gardien au G7 qui est quand même un vrai
gage de sécurité pour notre offre
mais bon encore une fois là il est il
joue pas tout seul il joue avec ça
en fait cette position elle
m'inquiéterait aussi pas mal avec les
deux couleurs mais tu as l'impression
quand même que les Noirs ont rien fait
de mal en fait et que les Blancs par
contre ils ont ils ont vraiment une
partie
encore déjà voilà donc du coup c'est
vrai que
de se respect par rapport à cet aspect
là on prend plutôt les Noirs parce qu'on
a l'impression que les blancs sont un
peu en ligne quoi mais par contre quand
tu vois la pendule tu vois que les Noirs
ont une heure cinq à la pendule contre
une heure 41 de carbonara donc karena à
1h41 au bout de 20 coups alors que tu
commences à 1h40
ben ça me laisse un peu perplexe tu vois
et
je me dis que bon il y a des idées
encore donc quand dès qu'on est karwana
comme ça et tu sais qu'il te passe une
grosse prépa qui rentre dans ma tête
ça peut aussi faire peur ce côté-là
simplement mais bon c'est vrai que
C3 mais ça a pas l'air de marcher ça
c'est sûrement pour ça qu'il a mis la
dame en F3 et que les blancs
pour pouvoir apprendre de la dame du
coup
que derrière leur pion et du coup le
pion s'écape pour l'instant il peut pas
aller jusqu'au bout de son idée et
typiquement si on pouvait manger B3 et
jouer avec cavalier A4 terminé tout de
suite
ouais
sauf que
évidemment un petit carbone a préparé
tout ça c'est des idées et ce courage
lui permet d'empêcher ça
on va arriver
et ben en fait il va falloir être précis
avec les avec
la précision
le premier arrivé qui va mater qui va
gagner
et une après saison peut faire pas de la
partie des deux côtés donc vaut mieux
mieux vaut ne pas pas se tromper et car
voilà pour l'instant il les rend dans sa
prépa donc c'est pas lui qui qui peut se
tromper pour l'instant c'est parti donc
en tout cas une partie à surveiller pas
mal de choses intéressantes
quand même de voir et donc on est
toujours à cette position donc c'est
terrible ça veut dire que
certainement il y a un trou dans sa
prépa soit il s'est trompé soit il y
avait un trou et il s'attendait pas à se
sacrifice de pièces
on peut remettre vite fait ce qu'on a
peut-être deux trois qu'on a derrière
c'est tout pour ceux qui étaient pas là
il y a une grosse demi-heure
ouais
cavalier C3
et on s'est arrêté
mais bon pour juste que le fou il sera
moins fort en A5
et puis tout ça et
dépense de 5 dames 8 ça c'est la grande
idée de vent de Forest et du coup on a
parlé de ce sacrifice de pièce parce
qu'on aurait pu défendre le cavalier de
par plusieurs manières on avait dit que
pardon excusez-moi
on avait dit que le coup apprend B5
était le meilleur coût de l'ordinateur
et l'idée en fait est assez incroyable
c'est en fait on a une place avec les
Noirs
il est gratuit mais après ça il faut
voir que quand même les les blancs
manger quand même deux pions pour la
pièce
et un troisième pion pour être en prise
bientôt donc pour l'instant non parce
qu'il y aurait dame prend c'est 3 mais
après Dame des 4 ici
on peut imaginer que si par exemple les
Noirs venaient à manger et ben on aurait
une position avec trois pions pour la
pièce et une avalanche de pions qui
arrive
ça fait un peu peur quand même
pourra jamais s'exprimer et bon ça se
voit là c'est visuel normalement
vous devez le ressentir ici vous avez
pas besoin d'être grand maître pour
sentir que ça va pas pour les Noirs
trop fort et du coup bonne forest ben
ouais il a dû
tu te tromper quelque part parce que
l'ordinateur il la voit tout de suite
cette ligne donc forcément que s'il
avait préparé ça il aurait dû s'en
rendre compte je sais pas à quel moment
il s'est trompé
je veux faire une petite surprise
incroyable j'étais en train de checker
et je crois que j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé
un petit peu ah non désolé fausse alerte
[Musique]
mais j'ai un peu compris
comment faire pour les pour réparer ce
problème
car je te montre en off regarde
en fait il faut juste des fois faire ça
et ça et ça revient voilà
malheureusement
c'est le truc bizarre en tout cas on a
on va pas très très bien mcdoceaux sur
la caméra et voir si un moyen que je
vous le mette un peu plus
un peu plus au centre
[Musique]
donc c'est le dernier coup et là
certainement que bonne fois c'est pas
échanger la dame il y a pas je peux pas
la centrale
dans le dur
le local de l'étape
gagné un tournoi qui écrit une énorme
surprise à l'époque il y a deux ans il
avait battu guéri on glisse de départage
maudit dans ce tournoi qui a fini je
sais plus j'ai 4 ou 5 fois de 5 x 2e 5
fois deuxième donc
il a battu carcène c'est l'année où
jamais il a plus de il a l'air très
affûté
quand tu quand tu prépares une surprise
et que finalement c'est toi qui est
difficile
c'est difficile du coup là je sais pas
ce que ce que peut jouer avant forest
c'est la partie
et il peut essayer de le comprendre ce
pion là mais bon c'est pas facile parce
qu'après je vous conseille quatre on
peut imaginer que même par exemple E5
celui de foot S5 peut être une idée il y
a plein de possibilités même B6 c'est
une grande idée ici
simplement jouer avec la barre de fou
aux trois petits rocs et juste très bien
niveau matériel j'ai trois points pour
la pièce pour la pièce la paire de fou
le centre
donc il faut pas penser en fait que j'ai
une pièce de mon avec les avec les
Blancs je vais matériellement en égalité
ça c'est important de d'y penser après
si les blancs font une apprécision qui
perdent un pion un truc comme ça là ça
peut être compliqué parce que du coup
j'ai quand même une pièce de plus quoi
mais si les pions sont actifs si on
arrive à garder cette avance de d'espace
et ben les blancs vont rester très bien
aussi
intéressante justement c'est d'aller
mettre un fond en dessin plutôt je pense
que tu entends c'est de jouer C4
derrière
et
donc c'est pas clair
je pense bel avantage blanc mais
difficile pour pour Abdou ici en cette
partie qui est qui va avoir
du Raffin
je pense
bonne soirée
d'Abdou mais c'est pas ce que je voulais
dire
à ce que je regarde comme je parle parce
que je pourrais dire plein de bêtises
multitas que du cerveau de tout ce qui
n'est pas au point
et non
pas du tout
ce genre d'évaluation
mais au-delà de l'évaluation de leur
dire c'est juste qu'en pratique
ça va être très dur parce que t'as pas
d'espace en plus c'est pas du tout ce
que tu avais prévu j'imagine pour une
forest donc et d'un point de pratique et
d'un point de vue psychologique
il doit être un peu au bout de sa vie
dans le Forest je pense ici
de parram c'est qu'il veut très vite
quoi et c'est un peu un
épaule en beaucoup moins fort et du coup
bah en fait le fort enfin le fait de
jouer vite ça peut lui permettre de
faire des imprécisions et
éventuellement à faire revenir
[Musique]
Jordan dans la dans la partie du coup
l'idée c'est de d'enfermer le cavalier
noir de l'empêcher de sortir il fait
plus de développer né en 17
et de dire que si tu fais si tu pousses
ton pion à 6 avec les noirs on va
essayer de casser il y aura toujours B6
qui mène pas va faire
c'est bizarre
en tout cas c'est juste mon ressenti il
a quand même pas développé ses pièces il
a pas ok
il veut empêcher les pièces de sortir
c'est clair mais du coup il faut pas
oublier qu'il a pas ressentir cette
pièce donc même un coup comme comme
cavalier français c'est une est un coup
qui peut se regarder même si j'aime pas
trop rendre la pièce
d'un autre côté je reprends la paire de
fou mais bon en fait voilà si je fais
rien d'extraordinaire avec les avec
les noirs et ben en fait je pourrais
jamais sortir imaginons que ça par
exemple
ici qui permet de sortir des pièces vu
qu'il y a un clouage mais l'idée en fait
c'est que si jamais j'arrive à faire en
sorte que
de la structure des blancs les pièces
noires neuron jamais et c'est l'idée en
fait je pense de param ici avec C6 donc
là il faut voir ce que clairement j'ai
pas le droit de vérifier la pièce sans
cesse
certainement un sacrifice
et sinon
les flèches et tout ça c'est toujours
l'autre donc c'est toujours à ce tout de
faire les flèches jouer les coups moi je
ne peux que parler
c'est certainement pour forcer donc les
Noirs avant de la pièce d'une façon
d'une autre reste à savoir dans quelles
conditions une fois si tu vas jouer tout
de suite ou plus tard genre jouer à 6
pour essayer de miner même si ça
menacera rien ça le problème
parce que la tour sera clouée
j'aimerais bien dessiner des trucs avec
les flèches mais j'ai pas j'ai pas la
main tu veux dessiner
oui non mais j'ai juste montré en tout
cas sur les variantes parce que ça aide
pour le chat
de me remettre des par rapport aux
caméras qui qui remarche
j'ai 18 caméras et
pour me repérer savoir qui est qui
j'avais marqué sur un bout de papier
mais les caméras ont changé toutes deux
noms et des petits avec qui est-ce en
solo
c'est ça
du coup
[Musique]
par exemple tout à l'heure j'avais une
caméra sur sur Prague donc j'avais écrit
Prague la caméra numéro 4 et maintenant
quand je sur la 4 et ben c'est 47 du
coup ça me permet de
d'être clair avec moi-même OK
du coup ok donc c'est ce qui se passe il
y a eu fou aussi je t'aime pour
par
du coup
vente forest
et là qu'est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
peut-être qu'il se dit du coup que
que
faire tourner tout à l'heure
donc là ici le problème c'est que là
j'ai la dame qui défend le fou c'est
Madame s'en va de la défense je perds
mon fou et si je viens en D7 il y a une
petite blague avec cavaler des sets
maintenant à
jouer quoi et une fois que les pièces
tactiles c'est plus grand la même chose
vous voyez les blancs qui ont pas encore
sorti leurs pièces
surtout c'est que les pions blancs vont
se faire bloquer c'est pour ça ça peut
être l'inconvénient de celle-ci c'est
quand tu as tes pions côte à côte comme
ils étaient avant on B5 C5 bah tu
comprends un champ devant toi de cases
et bien instant et puis on tue les
avances
ok moi je comprends l'idée il voulait il
voulait bloquer ses pièces là il vous
empêcher qu'elle sortir et c'est vrai
quand même que je sais pas faut penser
qu'à travers tellement tellement simple
naturel tu vois je garde en fait mon
amas de pièces quoi et après en
rajoutant une idée ça ça avait l'air
très très fort
c'est une position quand même que les
deux joueurs ne connaissent pas et du
coup ils se précipite ils ont quand même
pas loin de 4 heures chacun quand même
c'est parti là c'est dommage qui qu'il
joue aussi vite dans les positions aussi
concrètes quoi
je sais pas si il y a des écrans pour un
spectateurs aucune idée là si j'ai vu
dans la salle qui avait des écrans
d'accord ils ont des grands des parties
avec les secrétaires à côté
le matin c'était l'aveugle et la crème
c'était rapide
qu'il a la piscine j'avais croisé
parce que je dis bon vu les conditions
qui devaient avoir à l'hôtel c'était un
hôtel
face cinq étoiles enfin je dis bon
niveau de la bouffe donc je pense pas
que ça soit malheureux quoi non il est
parti au McDo et j'avais presque envie
de le laisser passer devant moi tu sais
mais ouais non c'était bien
tu es dans la rue sur la promo le soir
tu te promets mais tu rencontreras en
dessous enfin c'est génial en fait mais
vraiment super mais anecdote super
anecdote ce truc
j'avais vu je passe plus tu connais la
partie du Ventoux que contre une partie
des ventous contre contre caryakim une
nage d'orf avec un timbre prend le 6 de
divorceau
et je sais même que vous auriez parlé
dans l'ascenseur il y avait une anecdote
puisque c'était
dans l'ascenseur comme ça j'aurai un mec
random qui a été lui dire ah mais tu
aurais pu jouer ça ou je sais pas quoi
non
si c'était pas lui je crois
je sais plus mais je me souviens de
l'anecdote
pas le nom de la personne
mais je sais plus que c'était ouais mais
non c'était monstrueux j'avais vu mon
rosé Beach à Nantes cramique
j'avais pris des photos avec tous les
joueurs sauf mon rosé Beach morose et
lui c'était allé le voir pour prendre
une photo avec lui et il m'avait dit
je parle pas anglais alors que mec enfin
tu parles anglais quoi et moi je m'en
fous tu parles anglais photos et il me
dit OK
du coup bah il marche donc je le suis
parce que je me dis bah si il s'arrête
pas c'est qu'il veut prendre plutôt un
endroit donc je le suis et puis en fait
tu partais quoi il est parti en fait
donc je prends une photo mec il me dit
oui il part du coup je pense qu'on a pas
con c'est pas compris et sinon j'avais
eu Carlsen j'avais à rognan j'avais eu
tout le monde quoi
[Musique]
et non c'était vraiment cool franchement
ce tournoi c'est j'en garde des
souvenirs extraordinaires monsieur moi
je passais le bac j'ai pas assez le bac
et enfin pas le bac blanc en fait
c'était back blanche je me souviens et
j'avais une épreuve d'anglais
et je l'avais bâclé pour aller voir le
tournoi je m'en foutais
une épreuve qui durait deux heures moi
j'ai fait une demi-heure et je suis
parti voir les parties il y avait
personne qui jouait quoi
et non mais c'était vraiment génial donc
franchement si vous avez des éléments
comme ça dans votre ville à l'avenir
franchement FC d'y passer quoi c'est
génial j'ai vu que souvent il y avait il
y avait des tournois comment ça
s'appelait les
les ponts et les publics là il y a pas
longtemps c'était des comment ça
s'appelle
comme ça avec public il avait un c'était
un tournoi qui était déjà en Roumanie
avec Super bête
il y a pas forcément les publics tout le
temps je crois genre aux États-Unis à
Saint-Louis c'est pas si les publics
mais en Roumanie on avait en fait mais
bon juste c'est un tournoi pas loin si
jamais des fois qu'en France moi il faut
faire quoi c'est génial c'est juste
génial en fait
qui est souvenir de fou de ces
événements là
est-ce que tu connais moi la partie de
de Ding avec ce tourbé là ce tour bien
qui s'est passé ta cari français a été
joué par par vent de Forest il rend la
pièce
et voilà la pièce
sans perdre l'option C4 donc ouais donc
il a un pion de moins mais du coup il a
il a une
il a une il a un peu d'initiative
pas mal les cases noires enfin les cases
blanches des pièces c'est pas mal pour
les blancs quand même je pense c'est un
bel avantage blanc quand même
bon je sais pas peut-être pas ce qui est
le plus chiant en pratique pour les
noirs on verra comment ça évoluer est-ce
qu'on va faire un petit regazziding
ça serait génial
allez
de la technique on va voir si ça marche
ça refait toujours la même
après les joies elles sont peut-être
très matérialistes encore à la parade au
moins comme ça je suis sûr j'ai récupéré
ma pièce
j'ai un petit plus sans risque mais
peut-être mieux qu'un petit peu j'ai un
vrai plus avec ma paire de fou sans
risque alors que dans l'autre position
et ben c'est même si c'est plus agréable
à jouer c'est déséquilibré c'est trois
pions pour une pièce donc ça peut mal
tourner là normalement il peut plus
perdre ce genre de position
et du coup alors attends parce que Tour
européen il y a eu cavalier 5 fou B3
alors juste ok alors j'ai un peu du mal
à comprendre encore une fois cette tour
en bien qui a été joué
trois parce que le but c'était peut-être
d'ouvrir la colonne B et là du coup je
sais pas trop trop
quel objectif il a eu de faire tourner
parce qu'à la limite bon si il laissait
là ou à la limite si il faisait un truc
je sais pas moi prise et mais là ça fou
B3 c'est un coup bizarre pour moi
donc du coup
ah tiens il a mangé depuis 7 3
et peut-être que tu trouves un jour si
on joue ces deux par exemple
donc là il va manger ici je pense
à Nice à la base c'était à Monaco très
longtemps après il y a eu des problèmes
avec les hôtels de Monaco et ça a été
changé puis c'était au Pas de la
Méditerranée
donc sur la promo pendant
plusieurs années plusieurs années et
après je crois que les deux dernières
années et ben ils sont repartis sur
sur
Monaco parce que bon il voulait juste
le monsieur qui
le milliardaire qui subventionnément
comment ça se faire vieux il voulait
faire une ou deux éditions de plus et
arrêter
et
donc ils ont terminé là-bas d'ailleurs
je crois que la dernière année à Monaco
je suis passé une fois ou deux je suis
allé et c'était loin donc du coup
c'était compliqué pour un dialet et il y
avait gris qui avait joué événement la
dernière fois et il avait 16 ans
il avait fait d'heure un super temps
donc du coup du coup il a 4 ans de moins
c'est ça
c'est la meilleure année de naissance
vous savez
90 c'est une super génération sans
vouloir troll parce que il y a kariakine
il y a 45 il y a un VL il y a des pots
c'est une grosse génération 90
et
en fait le problème c'est que aucun de
ces gens-là ne connaît encore tout mais
je vous le dis
c'est la menace
un jour il sera là
compensations sur le renard qui peut
être assez faible
alors une idée thématique donc position
donc moi je vois souvent dans la
française par exemple les pions G5 G4
qui sont avancés des fois une une bonne
rupture peut être F3 donc F3 F3 c'est
pas possible pour l'instant parce que je
suis cloué mais une rupture à la casser
3 ça va être pas mal surtout c'est un
tour est en F1
était F3 ou F4
peut être une possibilité pour virer les
pièces et essayer de casser un peu tout
ça en fait parce qu'au final mon roi à
moi il en sécurité mais lui
ben il faut démolir quoi
surtout le pion a changé
par par noir et puis on peut se
retrouver faible si le pion G4 venait à
disparaître c'est pour ça que F3 pour
miner qui ont G4 point carrément avoir
du sens
pour faire pression sur F7 ensuite
B7 qui peut être un peu fait parfois
parce que les Noirs ils ont pas envie de
jouer B6 évidemment ça bloquerait leur
fou des cases noires donc il y a plein
de petits soucis à résoudre pour les
noirs
et finalement on pratique ça a l'air
plus sympa à jouer pour
erikasi avec son fameux tourbéen qui
commence à avoir un peu de sens
maintenant
alors ici il y a aussi une autre idée
qu'on peut pointer un peu c'est la case
F5 qui peut être qui peut être possible
par exemple bon cavalier 5 maintenant
j'aime pas perso parce que il faut
prendre F5 et puis on prend F5 et on a
l'impression que bah au final est morte
s'en sortent par contre je cavalier F1
cavalue E3 pour venir en F5 peut être
sympa quand tu installes un cavalier en
F5 il faut prendre j'ai l'autre Caval
qui va prendre quoi c'est l'idée
installer un cavalier c'est un peu
prendre pas mal de sens donc mettre un
cavalier ici intéressant et aussi bien
sûr votre idée de et que le fou le fou
des Noirs c'est intéressant à noter il
est en A7 il est dans une belle
diagonale mais du coup il est pas du
tout
à la protection du roi
[Musique]
il a fait pas mal la diagonale mais je
pense que du coup après
roi H1 et un pion F qui va avancer ça
m'a l'air pas mal hein
diagonale du vide nous disent Paul funky
après roi H1 se fout à 7 il est plus
c'est un peu une belle plante quoi mais
c'est ça donc justement maugré on l'a
dit que trois avec ma possible
maintenant mais d'abord on fait roi H1
et en plus tout ça pourra que l'idée en
tout cas dans ce type de position mais
en général quand on voit ça avec le roi
et derrière on a envie de tout casser et
pour tout cas c'est faut pas avoir peur
de poser le pion F donc souvent on vous
dit de pas bouger le pion en l'air parce
que bah c'est c'est dangereux le roi est
derrière et des relations ouvertes mais
dans l'autre côté vous voyez que le roi
noir est tellement découvert lui-même
qu'en fait on a besoin de d'aller
l'ouvrir et des fois pour l'ouvrir on a
besoin de nous aussi ça fait bien un
petit peu donc là par exemple bon c'est
un peu préparatoire c'est un peu long
mais pour F1 droit H1 F4 manière hyper
intéressante
F3 je t'aime pas peut-être F3 plus fort
pour manger et vraiment ouvrir la tour
ouvrir un peu tout le monde on a besoin
d'ouvrir cette position après ce plan-là
il a moins de sens dans cette position
là sans plateau elle est encore en E1
généralement quand on fait F3 on veut
quand même ouvrir la tour aussi donc
donc tout récent c'est pas toi c'est un
peu long en fait on va dire
roi H1
numéro 1 je pense ici parce que on veut
un jour faire F3 au F4 voyez et ensuite
voir si est-ce que je mets d'abord la
tour en F1 ou pas ou est-ce que je joue
F4 mais en tout cas on va acheter un
goût qui est hyper standard cette
position il y a un vis-à-vis entre froid
bah écoutez on s'enlève on enlève les
complications et on prépare des des
poussées
moi j'aime bien
erikasi dans cette partie là les amis
je pense qu'il peut faire un truc
mais je t'avoue que pour
pour le tournoi j'aimerais bien que Ding
je termine bien parce que je vous
rappelle que dans quelques mois
Ding va jouer le match du monde contre
un épaumener Hatchi et moi je suis un
supporter de Jing dans ce match je suis
vraiment pouring
en tout cas champion du monde connaît
pas non non plus mais Ding est trop
gentil en fait et il est très fort
d'échec enfin moi il m'impressionne tout
le temps plus que que nepo en fait
d'ailleurs j'ai vu l'interview de
Carlson elle sait qu'ils ont été arrivés
45 après ça annule éclair contre Ding
dans ce tournoi et on l'a demandé
qu'est-ce qu'il pensait du match entre
nezo et Ding et carcine a dit que
il pense que Ding c'est un meilleur
joueur d'échec et qui font qu'il le
prouve voilà donc
un petit peu plus fort d'après les ouais
mais que ils pensent que c'est un
meilleur joueur d'échec
mais voilà après quand tu arrives là-bas
et que tu vas faire un mauvais tournoi
juste avant t'es pas forcément en
confiance donc là il a perdu hier contre
Prague avec les Blancs
bon si hyper une deuxième partie
d'affilée
Ding c'est un genre qui peut sombrer
aussi on l'a vu encore aux candidats
où il était bon il y avait le covid il y
a eu plein de trucs un peu tu vois mais
il n'était pas du tout dans son
meilleur mood quoi
il a fait une première moitié de
candidat raté il avait bien fini la
deuxième puis là encore quand même ne
même pas la moitié du tournoi mais avoir
et pour répondre au chat si on touche un
pion une pièce qu'on a pas le droit de
jouer c'est un coup illégal
en partie lente en fait c'est pas grave
ça dépend si ton anniversaire tu le fais
remarquer déjà ça dépend c'est
volontaire ou non si touche
involontairement moi surtout là il y a
pas de problème et si tout le
volontairement tu te rends compte que tu
as pas le droit de jouer la pièce tu vas
voir quoi juste un avertissement mais il
y a pas de conséquences
ouais bon c'est toujours entièrement il
faut la jouer quoi après les gens
tu vas pas jouer ton pion F non si par
exemple là je veux prendre une pièce
avec mon coude sans faire exprès je
trouve une pièce bah écoute c'est la vie
enfin j'ai pas fait exprès quoi tu vois
il faut que ce que ce soit volontaire
quoi j'ai pas mis la main pour tous ces
rompu quoi tu vois j'ai sa volontaire
non tu n'arrête pas d'avoir raison quoi
c'est pas grave ça arrive
après si tu fais à chaque coup ok je
veux bien mais normalement tu vois
c'était si tu touches ton pion F
volontairement là tu as pas le droit
qu'est-ce qui se passe
si je volontairement et que j'ai pas le
droit
tu peux pas le jouer
mais est-ce que tu as quand même
peut-être un avertissement parce que
comme c'est toujours un coup de gueule
en fait non
bah non c'est pas un collègue
un coup légal il faut même avoir appuyé
sur la pendule même si je joue un coup
regarde moi je regarde je sais pas je
fais ça
ok ben c'est un coup légal quoi mais
j'attends sur la pendule si j'ai pas
appuyé sur la pendule et ben c'est pas
considéré comme couplégal
par contre je dois le jouer voilà donc
je pense pas que j'ai paniqué de temps
ici je pense pas parce que j'ai pas pu
sur la pendule
toutes ces questions là ça normalement
impact quand même quasiment jamais en
partie lente c'est plus en bide sont
rapides que ça peut un peu se passer des
choses il y a ça lente normalement
c'est vraiment exceptionnel si un
incident comme ça
mais si j'ai pas joué il y a plus on a
pendule Connect
mais ça fait longtemps la règlement
change tout le temps je suis pas je suis
pas à jour mais je me souviens je suis
sûr de ça que si j'ai pas besoin c'est
pas considéré comme quoi les gars du
coup ben
si tu fais un coup même si c'est un coup
de gueule quand il peut se la pendule
normalement tu as pas de enfin je sais
pas
faudra demander un arbitre un arbitre
si on a l'arbitre dans la salle
on arrive dans la salle
hello pas tous comment se passe
c'est la pièce n'a pas de couleur oui on
veut notre pièce bah oui
un coup est considéré comme illégal
seulement si le joueur achève son cou on
a pu recevoir
je pense assez jamais vu
attendez des vidéos comme ça oui mais
oui mais là une cadence une heure trente
comme ça
en blit rapide oui ça arrive même des
joueurs d'ailleurs sauf que marrante
Nakamura
dans un piste officiel un tournoi
officiel il met son roi il touche le roi
de Nakamura sur une case adjacente au
roi adverse Nakamura
le roi de nakay il est en D4 le roi de
vie qu'il est en F2 il a joué trois
écrivait
qui jouait contre alors je sais plus qui
mais un grand maître un fort grand
maître à 2007 mais pas un genre de
l'élite mais un peu moins fort et en
fait Carlsen fait chaque roi roi du gars
le gars a pas vu qu'il y avait échec et
il a mis le roi de personnes en échec
car ça n'a pas vu qu'il avait fait
chèque et du coup car enseigne il a fait
un autre coup en fait les deux rois
étant échec
et du coup l'arbitre enfin le joueur il
a appelé la rabat
toi aussi mais en fait c'est le dernier
coup qui qui prime donc personne perd la
partie
et gagne il y a une vidéo sur Youtube
je sais plus comment qui c'était il y a
combien de CO ou un mec comme ça ou
vraiment il fait couler les gars l'autre
il voit pas il fait un coup illégal par
dessus et qu'un seul qui refait encore
un coup illégal il y a eu et du coup
personne qui perd la partie parce qu'à
l'époque c'était cool les gars par la
partie non maintenant c'est le deuxième
une arkief peut-être une archive c'est
possible
possible merci merci corsof mais la
partie elle est enfin la vidéo en tout
cas elle est sur Youtube elle est
marrante
en échec et si l'autre doit pas du coup
il joue il joue un coup mais vu que avec
ton échec le coup qui jouait était
illégal puisqu'il devait signer échec et
donc il pouvait réclamer et ben moi j'ai
jamais fait personne
il y a des gens qui tentaient ça
mais non mais en fait tu fais ça tu as
pas de face quoi mais mais
genre ils étaient plus de temps et bon
ben tu vois compliqué trouver sur la
figue
pourquoi ça nous règle la fille en fait
la précision la main les obligations ont
besoin d'avoir le premier coup les gars
alors qu'on a pas la parole ça je savais
ça
j'étais pas bien j'étais en train de
souffrir parce que moi quoi et il m'a
fait un bruit légal et moi je pensais
avoir gagné du coup moi je lui dis bah
écoute tu as perdu quoi et non c'est un
début de changer quoi genre trois jours
avant j'avais changé quoi je dis vas-y
quoi
du coup j'ai eu une huile de rajout mais
bon j'étais tellement foutu que j'ai
quand même perdu la partie et mais ça
avait changé en juillet je crois quelque
chose et le tournoi et comme on sait je
sais pas avoir le 4 juillet quoi comme
ça
et à quatre jours près j'ai perdu la
partie
et j'étais assez dingue
sous lava en rapide c'est une finale de
foot couleur non de foudre même couleur
et mon pion elle est Adam il a déplacé
il a changé de diagonale son four c'est
un fou de case blanche il est devenu fou
de quasiment pour essayer d'arrêter
direct
venant de sa part clairement lui
c'était c'était pas fait exprès
je pense aussi que c'était pas fait
exprès
moi je dis différent avec cette personne
donc je pourrais être des fois me disant
mais non je te dis que que pas du tout
il est sur l'échiquier c'est vraiment un
gentleman
voilà
ok alors il y a des parties qui sont
intéressantes on peut le voir Carter
surprise à vous à vous donner
voir si je peux changer de caméra on va
essayer en tout cas
avec
ces histoires dans tous les gars en fait
faut toujours arrêter la pendule pour
répondre aux questions et appeler
l'arbit en fait avant de jouer son coup
avant quoi que ce soit si jamais toi tu
joues ton tu joues ton coup après que
ton adversaire a fait quelque chose que
tu es stimuli légal bah ça c'est trop
tard faut toujours arrêter la porte de
la peine Rabbit
sur le coup après tu pourras plus
ouverte pour les fours on en parlait on
faisait si le centre venait à voler en
éclat qu'est-ce qui se passe il aurait
pu l'histoire de bons fous mauvais faux
et on voit que ce fou à trois maintenant
il est magnifique
ce fois magnifique il empêche les noirs
de Rocket
et
[Musique]
et moi j'aime bien les blancs
ils doivent peut-être
qu'un seul il vient de sacrifier ça
tourne donc c'est très intéressant la
position il vient de laisser sa tour à 1
pour jouer sur les cases noires si vous
êtes l'offrande
donc il aurait la paire de fou et les
cases noires
ok c'est un choix très intéressant on va
voir s'il relève le défi
forcément il doit le considérer c'est la
première chose qu'on regarde ici
et le grand rock évidemment ce que à
quoi je réfléchis aussi une option pour
les Noirs puisque pour l'instant on n'a
pas le droit de faire le petit rock
ouais
et son adversaire pour voir un petit peu
ce qu'en pense soin de sacrifice alors
tu peux revenir un petit peu en arrière
pour voir
je vais venir en arrière
technique de spoiler funky et je prends
et je réfléchis après ça ça marche mieux
en Bullet quand on partira en général
perso
j'aime beaucoup en tout cas cette idée
un sacrifice de qualité excuse-moi un
petit truc donc
qui est à cette thématique ici on veut
ouvrir la position c'est normal profitez
de l'avance de développement et de
l'avance centrale donc presque avaler
prend foutait 7 donc voilà sur petit rat
j'aurais sûrement mangeant ces 6 puis on
prend et
taper sur le sur le pion en C6 donc
pour attaquer ici profitant du clouage
aurait été intéressant il y a eu fou des
7 cavalier F3 donc qui refuse l'échange
au final
[Musique]
sur le roi noir celui qui avait des
cartes qui peut arriver j'ai pas mal de
jeux j'adore c'est difficile pour pour
les Noirs
les débats en tout cas donc c'est
intéressant
en tout cas ça fait une position ça fait
hyper peur en tout cas
parce que
je peux encore jouer C4 par exemple pour
pas qu'il rock c'est difficile en
pratique de de prendre décision surtout
quand on regarde scène et qu'on se dit
que Ben qu'on a cette position avec les
Noirs quoi c'est pas facile
il peut aussi se dire que là il joue
clairement aussi pour le gars avec les
Noirs en fait s'il arrive à consolider à
faire quelques échanges c'est la montage
alors que jusque là il jouait
certainement plus pour l'égalité ce qui
est normal
c'est vraiment encore une fois un jeu à
trois résultats c'est qu'un scène il
veut prendre des risques il a besoin de
gagner
non mais cette position tu vois il y a
un truc en plus qui est important
au-delà du matériel au-delà de tout ça
c'est que cette pollution elle m'a l'air
en tout cas très facile à jouer en
pratique pour les blancs les blancs le
plan des blancs est assez simple je me
les tours au centre je vais sur les
cases noires et cetera alors que pour
les Noirs il faut jouer hyper précis
quoi
et
donc je suis un
en pratique ça m'a l'air dur pour pour
Abdou mais
essaie de voir un peu imaginons grand
vrac d'Orient
que les blancs ils menacent déjà quelque
chose ou pas est-ce que cahier des
cartes par exemple ça je veux pas le
manger on va expliquer pourquoi
peut-être ce pion il est voilà un jour
peut-être je pourrais le manger mais là
c'est pas forcément mon idée principale
parce qu'on a peur que le noir et
justement du contrôle sur la colonne sur
le roi blanc donc c'est pas forcément un
pion que j'ai envie de manger par contre
ce que je voudrais essayer de faire
c'est éventuellement essayer de venir
taper sur charisme et ouvrir un petit
peu ces colonnes c'est quoi après plus
je change de pièces moins je peux
attaquer parce que moi j'aurais de
pièces mais
ok vous voyez que les Noirs quand même
manquent de de pièces sur case noire
notamment le fou le Fouquet noir qui
leur fait un peu défaut et du coup si je
peux arriver à mettre une pièce en D6
par exemple ça peut être sympa mais bon
encore une fois c'est très dur à faire
mais c'est car c'est une potion qui est
complètement déséquilibrée il peut
passer n'importe quoi personne qui peut
un peu trop pousser Abdou qui peut très
bien défendre
partie à trois résultats
mais il a pas encore justement cette
qualité
quand même
est-ce qu'il peut jouer d'autres j'ai
envie de dire que c'est pas faut prendre
un c'est difficile de trouver un coup
parce que tu peux pas remonter
les deux fous
ça peut être possible
comment je défends toutefois ça part
direct dans la 5 je suis fou à 4 il va
manger là et après je peux plus manger
parce que je perdrai ici
[Musique]
comme ça
tu peux le jouer je pense à mon avis
l'idée c'est que je vais garder la part
de fou pour les blancs moi je vois deux
coups je vois ça aussi
mais dans l'idée ça reste ça reste un
petit peu la même après faut prendre
pour reprendre et ben je t'empêche le
rock et toujours pas mal d'activer sur
la colonne B la colonne C
ça me fait peur en tout cas tout ça
ça me fait peur et en fait moi ce qui me
pose problème c'est que vraiment là il
faut que Abdou soit vraiment hyper
précis dans cette position sinon il peut
perdre quasiment instant
la position peut être très difficile
alors que cancer qualité de moi mais il
a des compétences de toute façon au pire
matériel avec tes petits pions on avait
dit j'essaie tu vois mais
il se passe quoi si tu reviens en
arrière
par manger la tour qui pose la question
en faux
des six toujours qui a une idée mais
alors je sais pas si maintenant c'est
possible
de manger cette
caméra sinon fallait tirer
pas trop mais en pratique c'est une
autre chose en pratique c'est votre
histoire
parce que les gens sont pas des
ordinateurs
prises d'enfants
et là
un peu ce qui se passe quoi
mais c'est très chaud c'est très chaud
Abdou peut défendre et gagner
comme peu surmater je pense qu'on a
vraiment tous les étapes aussi dans
cette partie
parce que une autre partie qui peut être
intéressante
que c'était très chaud avec la poussée
du roi on va aller voir ça direct je
vais vous mettre une caméra dessus
qui nous ont rejoint notre temps
et ce qu'il a toujours autant regardé il
a plus d'une heure d'avance à la pendule
mais la position c'est simplifiée voilà
pour revenir en arrière
alors que s'est-il passé en starcable F3
là il y a eu pour ab8
ok
tourab8 qui a l'air assez logique
mais les tours sur la colonne B qui est
ouverte avec le fou B2 la tour 4 jouer
par par famille
de manière ingénieuse ok en passant par
la quatrième
c'est pas non plus totalement improbable
[Musique]
ok donc du coup c'est vite a été joué
j'ai découvert et le fou ça c'est
intéressant c'est pour revenir
et parvenir en plus sur des bonnes cases
comme ça pour venir attaquer aussi le
l'ouragan
je commence à avoir un peu peur
un peu le débat parce que du coup
bah ça va forcer les changes
il est obligé d'aller dans la colonne
évidemment c'est pas du tout ce dont on
a envie catastrophique
de partout ce serait ce serait trop
difficile
dans mes trois dans le pré puis on prend
et pourquoi pas
est-ce que je peux manger le 5
3G 7
[Musique]
au lieu de
qui va manger la tour du coup
qui permet de de manger la la dame avec
le fou donc on mange nous on mange une
tour mais on mangera avec le fou
après ça reste pas encore je comprends
encore
la nuance c'est quoi c'est que
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'il a plein
et les deux joueurs ont une structure un
petit peu bizarre mais c'est vrai que
maintenant les tours blanches peuvent
être mal placés si il y a plus de dames
et si j'ai plus rien sur la clonage
que les faiblesses des noirs
donc du coup
je vois pas là comment il gagnerait
cette partie ici
donc sa grosse prépa finalement saut a
du bien réagir
soit bien joué là qui peut être en prise
plein de fois plus tard sur le long
terme et aussi de tomber trois qui est
un petit peu en souffrance en tant que
position donc
pas simple réagir je pense que ici en
pratique les noirs sont mieux même si
j'ai une structure un peu cassée mais
les blancs aussi en fait au final donc
une jeune qui met une tour en E6 par
exemple qui va plus facilement défendre
ces 6 alors que 5 plus dur à défendre
et en plus là sur des coups comme B4
plus tard c'est une faiblesse
ou des C5 en tout casser donc je peux me
débarrasser de mes faiblesses aussi
donc petit avantage pour les Noirs j'ai
envie de dire léger peut-être
ça risque de simplifier vers une nulle
surtout qu'il a quand même de simplifier
ouais il a 22 minutes
il est pas très bien autant donc
cette partie quand même
alors on voit quinzaine il y a eu grand
rock comme prévu est-ce qu'on irait pas
voir un petit aronium qui meurt qu'on a
pas trop envie depuis le début de partie
je crois au tout début qu'est-ce que ça
donne
une petite
juste
ça ne me fait pas peur
donc du coup donc c'était une italienne
une espagnole
et du coup il joue à cavalier baby set
C4 C6
ok donc c'est une sorte de
cette structure un petit peu
ça peut être une structure de ce type
comment dire
[Musique]
ça peut être silienne
donc ouais ouais donc à 5 tu veux jouer
à 4 pour essayer de t'ouvrir tout
échanger pendant je mange en métro
[Musique]
donc à un moment donné il va manger là
et manger là et c'est d'avoir cinq
contre cinq
on se retrouve avec des pions plus que
un peu au centre et à l'endroit et
généralement c'est assez difficile de
gagner aussi
un petit plus qu'ils ont un peu plus
d'espace mais ça va être ultra solide
pour les noirs et
ça fait souvent des nul cette position
au club de Nice et on avait joué un
match contre le club de grâce et non
tu avais joué un jour à plus de 2700 et
l'eau j'avais les blancs
et c'était une partie là je crois après
les anges de pions c'était une position
assez plate
de faire plusieurs fois nulle qu'il
finit par perdre une finale vraiment
bêtement quoi mais c'était pour le coup
à cause du vélo du mec je pense
tu avais un peu
oui d'expérience quoi tout à fait mais
c'était ce genre de position comment je
connais j'étais là j'étais présent
je me souviens contre j'avais joué un
autre un autre grand maître à 2006 60 il
avait moi je cours au bœuf
et non pardon Paco probable
mais c'est pas le même
j'avais pris l'avantage à contre petit
Benco à l'époque et bon malheureusement
la compréhension voilà a été largement
au-dessus de moi et j'ai perdu
facilement la position un peu mieux mais
ouais je m'étais fait éclater ma grasse
c'était le mieux avec une armada grand
maître
jusqu'au 7e quoi
peut-être pas septième mais
au moins 6 quoi le monstrueux de
l'équipe il faut les monter en Top 12
on n'est pas je crois qu'ils ont bien
réussi avec
ça c'est
un couteau
on va parler
donc assez normal les Noirs prennent la
colonne ah ils n'empêche toi et du coup
peut-être Damas 2 va arriver avec des
échanges
massifs sur la colonne a donc position
qui est assez
égal j'ai l'impression
ça va pas trop trop de problèmes ici
a pas été liquidée mais à tout moment
ça peut se passer voilà
son petit plus il a un légère avantage
disparaissent mais j'y crois pas pas non
plus surtout que c'est plus harmonial
comme flamboyant comme on disait en
début du stream il y a quand même moins
tranchant que il y a quelques années
même quelques mois
il a fait des parties plutôt très solide
mais juste ce je me permette de couper
parce que je viens de trouver
la pareillement
pour que tu vois juste ta ligne
un truc comme ça
j'y crois pas
06 71 ans
[Musique]
c'était en 2016 en N1 groupe C Nice
grâce j'ai pas la confiance à la
personne qui a rentré je pense qu'elle
s'est trompé
ah non je voulais pas le montrer là
malheureusement bon c'est pas grave
et toi tu avais joué
dans un autre truc je l'ai joué encore
et il m'avait complètement éclaté
il m'avait mis je crois c'était du 15
minutes à la pendule 15 plus quelque
chose à la fin de la partie quand
j'abandonne il a 13 quoi 13 minutes moi
je te rends tomber massacré beaucoup
trop fort comme à l'Eco
très très bon rapide
mais bon c'est à l'époque où c'était
Monaco Cannes mais moi j'étais à Nice
mais c'était le cas c'était comme ça
en 2016
alors ouais alors on s'arrêtait à fou
aussi sous des 4 avec cavalerons
donc il y a eu il y a eu Dame des 7
[Musique]
c'est bizarre parce que tu vois plus
tard il va y avoir une rupture sans SS5
ça va arriver trop vite mais donc c'est
vraiment le coup
du gambler j'ai envie de dire je pense
non
je pense pas
pardon je pense pas que que vu la
situation du tournoi il a envie de
prendre des risques comme ça
donc s'il continue comme ça nul avec les
noirs et qui est très bon il sera très
bien
donc donc
F7 qui est assez logique on a envie de
venir sûrement doubler les tours sur la
colonne 9 un jour et éventuellement les
tours
au centre donc Dame des quatre qui a eu
une prise qui est
donc à 5 par exemple prends la cage de
cavalier en B6 fixer un petit peu la
structure peut-être plus tard je B4
prend un peu d'espace aussi
ce qui veut faire c'est changer les
cavaliers tout simplement et je pense
que je pense que Prague avec peu de
temps la pendule peut-être qu'il a un
vais avoir une position tranquille et
peut-être même de viser la nul ici
le long terme donc ouais c'est une
position très très instruction à 5 peut
aussi être faible chez les Blancs si les
blondes jouent pas B4 un moment donné
donc non on devrait clairement avoir une
nulle dans cette partie
à partir de deux jours qui se met un peu
faire des imprécions et que peu presser
mais je pense que eux ils sont tous les
deux contents de faire nul
il reste sur une grosse performance la
ronde d'avance un bon résultat pour les
deux joueurs
la position est très guéri est très bien
en tournoi il est leader pour l'instant
il a les Noirs
contre Prague qui est pas du tout un
client du coup
oui ça ça
vraiment permet aux joueurs de de
Fighter quoi être attaquer enfin
toujours pour gagner quoi mais en tout
cas vu le tableau du tournoi avec tous
ces joueurs jeunes tu vois tu as un
goûter tu as avant de Forest tu as un
bon paramétique qui est un joueur qui
joue pour le gars irrégasi ta Prague tu
as Abdou bon tous ces gens-là qui
vraiment qui qui progressent ta caméra
aussi qui progresse qui qui ont envie de
prouver un peu des choses quoi avec bien
sûr les caresses les guéris les gens
aussi qui veulent essayer de gagner des
parties c'est intéressant quoi donc
franchement c'est
plutôt là
il y a pas beaucoup de gros événements
du monde mais en partie lente
il va falloir attendre il y a la Coupe
du Monde et Le Grand Suisse qui vont
avoir lieu l'été
mais c'est dans longtemps quoi
et avant il y a le grand gesto il y a
que deux épreuves je crois qu'ils jouent
en lente le reste c'est du rapide et du
bled
moins en moins de tournois en partie
lente en fait qui se joue
ordinateur alors attends on n'aimait pas
bon on avait dit un roi H1 pour essayer
de faire F4 ou F3 on peut trouver ça
assez assez
logique et après cavalier F5 on a vu
qu'on n'avait pas à cause de fulpoint F5
par exemple
[Musique]
ça veut dire intéressant
d'autres cavaliers 3 puis aussi H4 qui
peut arriver
parce que son cavalier trop tu peux pas
je te retrouve à cause de fou prendre 3
donc
mais
ok
pour les noirs
et les noirs on veut cavaler les sites
qu'on a pas eu tout regarder du coup
mais
[Musique]
du coup
on n'arrête pas de dire du coup il y a
quelqu'un qui a fait la remarque dans le
chat le type de langage ultime est
beaucoup de gens du coup pars vite
surtout on parle de coups aux échecs
et du coup on va essayer de parier le
jeu
par voie de conséquence
[Rires]
donc
cavaler j'ai 6
bye H4 enfermé ce commentaire de notes
là
donc
moi je dis donc
H4 c'est l'idée et
peut-être que les blancs de jouer H4
eux-mêmes pour empêcher les normes
de gagner une pièce c'est un vrai
problème qu'il faut résoudre
[Musique]
non plus
il faut trouver une un truc parce que là
c'est vrai que H4 c'est une réelle c'est
une réelle menace
et j'ai pas de cavalier H6 avec un
réglages 6 rois j'ai cavaler prend F7
c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
j'ai encore dit du coup
donc pas l'interpète
du coup
mais du coup ça c'est un peu comme le
jeu ni oui ni non quoi et du coup tu as
envie de le dire quoi maintenant que
qu'ils l'ont dit c'est insupportable
quoi
c'est un peu comme ni oui ni non je peux
plus
donc ouais on fait quoi du coup après
moi je pense là moi je me rends même pas
compte mais
moi je m'en fous
que je joue à ce jeu pendant 7 heures je
vais devenir tout en fait
tu veux bien essayer pendant une
demi-heure mais après on arrête quoi
du coup ça marche ok pour te faire
plaisir
[Rires]
moi c'est pas facile de comprendre la
nuance est-ce que le roi noir est mieux
pareil j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il a
mis en H8 que ici l'avantage abrite mais
donc est-ce que c'est un sens de faire
ces échecs et quelques clavier déjà
est-ce que il a envie de faire nul en
tout cas de faire cette offre
potentielle de répétition du coup
ok je pense que Ding il veut sa partie
voir ce qui se passe je pense pas qui il
est envie de forcement de faire nul ou
pas enfin juste et
candidats à la place de ces échecs
de jouer H4 il a joué H3 là je me monte
s'il y a pas jusqu'à 4 et j'ai 3
la caméra sur le joueur parce que j'ai
oublié ça
fait quand même une case de repli au
four ça peut toujours servir et puis
surtout ça mine le plus de la carte ça
menace concrètement de manger en G4 de
reprendre avec la dame
la dame arriverait directement à la
sauce sur le roi noir et après sur le
cavalier G6 et donc
F7 est cloué
déjà plus dur quand il y a pas les
flèches
je vais juste
vous remettre les caméras mais ça va ça
va encore bugger et
[Musique]
du coup pardon en fait l'idée c'est que
sur H3 à la base je pensais faire H4 et
surtout H2 jouer G3 et la U15
et ben ça va faire une pièce pour
pour les blancs qui pourront pas manger
je crois par contre ce que ça m'y a dit
ce qui est très pertinent et très fort
c'est d'en prendre jusqu'à ici et sur
pion prend ici ben je mange là parce que
du coup vous voyez
le pion F7 qui est qui est cloué et la
dame qui va manger ici et là ça va être
matte au prochain ok donc H3 a été joué
donc H4 est pas possible clairement
donc qu'est-ce qu'on peut essayer de
faire du coup puis on prend c'est chaud
pour les deux joueurs et je pense que
puis en France d'ailleurs maintenant
très très mauvais coup
ça a l'air extrêmement fort en tout cas
on menace ça
tu as des coups de défense comme dame J6
et 6 pour venir défendre un peu ce
cavalier mais malgré tout c'est alors
quand même pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle pour les Noirs à cause de de la
pression et de l'attaque sur le roi
blanc on voyait que les pièces blanches
arrivent très facilement en fait à
l'attaque donc
on veut essayer ce genre de choses
donc est-ce qu'on pourrait faire sur H3
à la place de
manger là où c'est là
un point sur le cavalier c'est un
problème majeur
manger c'est pas l'idée avant il n'a pas
mis cavalier ici
pardon
à sa place ici pour menacer un petit un
petit H4 du coup comme tout à l'heure
l'idée de faire h4g3 finalement
j'aime bien les blancs ici parce que du
coup là il y a plus qu'à 5 non plus noir
qui était aussi un coup qu'on voulait
faire donc là
un jour et d'ouvrir la colonne F pour ma
tour intéressant pour pour le blanc
j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup les blancs
ici je préfère pour répondre à la
question de cuir applicable toi tu
préfères plutôt les blancs ici ou les
Noirs à jouer en pratique
j'ai l'impression que mes pièces sont
mieux placées et que sur le long terme
en fait les Noirs ont poussé leurs pions
donc tu peux penser qu'ils sont en train
d'attaquer mais au final c'est plutôt
les blancs tu vois la puissance des
pièces blanches etc il est possible
qu'il y a
encore une fois en pratique je préfère
ça moi moi je suis un grand attaque donc
je préfère je préfère voilà je préfère
jouer l'attaque avec tes blancs je
devais choisir je pense que je prendrai
les blancs
et pourquoi pas H4 direct si je vais
prendre n'est pas un coup alors
c'était possible il avait préféré H3
pour créer une menace concrète sur G4
mais HK direct c'était jouable
la position et je prends c'est quand
même un coup puisque la barre de cabuse
effectivement ça fait très peur qui peut
rejouer H3 peut-être
de tenir même si dans 3 peut-être je
sais pas
qui est interdit elle prend donc dame
prend fourchette on récupère la pièce
mais comme dit Samy ça donne des ça fait
des échanges donc bon ce que vraiment de
base les blancs quand même un pion de
moins donc est-ce que je change de
vitesse ça favorise des blancs pas
forcément
mais H4 c'est un super coup
au final
parce que puis on prend damla après il
faut calculer clairement concrètement
est-ce que Ben est-ce que c'est possible
de le savoir
c'est très très tactique très concret à
cette position
en plus
il y a plein de pièces à calculer dans
tous les sens donc c'est facile de se
tromper les joueurs sont obligés de bien
vérifier si les lignes dans leur calcul
mais tu vois l'idée d'un projet si c'est
cavaliers 7 tu peux presque la voir à
l'envers en fait avec les noirs avec
Peter faut prendre F5 et d'un projet 3
donc en fait on a chacun le même
c'est très riche
tu ne rapporte rien à nous
personnellement
après moi je stream aussi j'ai ma chaîne
perso donc
je t'invite à passer en tout cas pour
ceux qui connaissent pas ma chaîne vous
savez que je stream je stream hier soir
pendant
la joindre repos du de l'événement et
donc c'est sympa on a fait un petit
speedrun à 1400 hello j'ai ramé pour
passer 1400 hello c'était dur je n'ai
perdu d'ailleurs
la partie qui enfin le stream qui qui
ira d'ailleurs sur Youtube très très
bientôt et pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas ma chaîne je vous invite à à y
passer le stream régulièrement que des
échecs d'ailleurs et j'ai aussi ma
chaîne youtube peut-être s'invite tu
peux me faire un petit saute
plus loin espace tout faire
donc
n'hésitez pas à visiter ma chaîne et
surtout à surtout à
follow ça coûte rien
et donc donc voilà et d'ailleurs je suis
ma chaîne Youtube c'est tout fait chèque
donc n'hésitez pas aussi à passer
je suis tout nouveau sur Youtube j'ai
qu'une vingtaine de vidéos c'est tout
tout
nouveau pour moi et merci du coup il va
du lundi
[Musique]
des duels les plus intéressants je pense
de la ronde on a deux trois parties qui
se dirigent la prior la nuit on a
quelques autres où ça a l'air très chaud
je te propose qu'on revienne quand même
sur
sur quinzaine non ça reste qu'un scène
on a envie de savoir comment ça va se
décanter
alors je vais retourner sur 45 je vais
mettre la bonne petite caméra
en tout cas ça compte psychologiquement
il sait qu'il a déjà fait donc il a une
position où
tout est possible
qui est
nouveau dans le circuit mais qui a quand
même déjà fait ses preuves il avait
comment il a un joli tableau de sache et
de chasse et c'est un joueur qui n'a pas
peur clairement ouais et donc en fait il
avait bon aux Olympiades il est
médaillés d'or
avec son équipe
l'Ouzbékistan
il a été champion du monde de partir
rapide il y a deux ans
lors des championnats du monde aussi de
16 960 et ben il a commencé avec avec 10
sur 10 ce qui voulait dire je pense
quasiment
et
deux autres joueurs à 2006 2007 et donc
il aura mis quasiment 5 6 0 d'affilée
et vraiment il est hyper impressionnant
en tout cas il a un style assez efficace
et il est hyper motivé si vous le voyez
si vous regardez juste comment
son attitude en fait dans l'échiquier
vous voyez que c'est un genre
extrêmement sérieux extrêmement appliqué
qui veut bien faire et
très motivé aussi et en tout cas
en tout cas intéressant je pense de le
suivre au fur et à mesure
pas de bluff il était manger espion et
pour manger ou pas il a pas continué à
manger ça faisait un peu peur
vous voyez qui est assez joli en fait
l'idée c'est que il va y avoir une
découverte là dessus plus tard et que du
coup pour pouvoir manger la dame et
bouger mon fou avec des couvercles il
faut que le rat blanc arrive sur une
case blanche accessible par le fou donc
là par exemple pour prendre échec et une
fois que je fais reprendre les deux et
ben j'ai fout H3 échec avec découverte
sur la dame donc du coup je vais pouvoir
manger donc ça c'est pas possible
maintenant manger à H7 ben bon
[Musique]
derrière
c'est
même sans calculer en fait tu as pas
envie en fait généralement tu calcules
pas trop au cas tu te dis où là ça ça
donne du jeu quoi donc
on m'a pas trop envie de s'aventurer
là-dedans en général
donc il a mangé un pion il est revenu en
B2 cases
donc tu arrives pas à contrôler cette
case décide de toute façon
je suis pas sûr parce que après il faut
prendre le fou qui serait à la fois
défenseur mais aussi à la fois
attaquant offensif là sur la diagonale
blanche j'aime pas trop la prise en C6
en tout cas par contre on peut imaginer
des fois le cavalier des quatre il y a
il y a un clouage quand même sur sur ce
cavalier
une pression sur le bout
position était très chaude en stuff
maintenant qu'elle a cette colonne j'ai
ouverte les deux joueurs ont de
l'attaque
j'ai du mal à évaluer franchement
archers
c'est comme tu le disais ce fou de casse
blanche on aimerait qu'il attaque qui
défendent à la fois par exemple si on
fait pas faut H3 ou fougères
parce que il y a un problème sur ces 6
je peux pas à la fois attaquer à la fois
défendre derrière il se passe quoi là là
je mange
mais ça a l'air déjà difficile
suivi de tout reprendre et tourmente
c'est pas si grave encore pour l'instant
oui il manque une tour à carcienne
donc c'est pas si si stupide
comme on disait le problème c'est que ça
donne un temps sur ton G6 gratuit en
fait il y a ça
et puis c'est moi qui va attaquer donc
je peux pas trop M6
on avait dit que c'était dangereux en F7
ça perd en ligne avec ton congédie on
avait dit là je peux pas là je peux pas
là je peux mais du coup j'ai pas le
clouage quand même
moi ça m'a l'air assez logique au final
d'imprimer deux
donc je peux défendre même si ça a l'air
très dangereux pour moi soit écoute il
leur dit à calculer que concrètement tu
ça va pas souvent il va calculer que ça
mais ça il faudra un ordre super
puissant
au fond dehors je sais pas combien pour
qu'on sache vraiment ça donne quand j'ai
déjà mais d'un point de vue humain
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
les deux colonnes sur le roi ça fait
très peur
sans calculer après
je travaille avec les Noirs c'est une
question intéressante
ici du coffret d'un B2
fois je crois j'ai deux têtes alors déjà
est-ce que ça c'est possible
on a toujours ce thème a priori de dame
prend qui va marcher pas de raison ah
oui d'apprendre ça marche encore je suis
bête
pour après
du coup sur sur dame B deux fois je
crois peut-être juger 3 en vrai
dangereux un peu en tout cas
[Musique]
quand même près aussi à revenir en
défense d'un coup
c'est dur hein
ici a du mal à venir ranger deux
[Musique]
sa force à jouer G3 mais G3 c'est pas un
coup que les blancs sont gênés de jouer
au contraire
donc voilà peut-être pas une bonne idée
par contre
vu que ça a l'air de marcher c'est
peut-être très intéressant parce que sur
fougère justement j'ai trois et
impossible puisqu'on mangerait le canal
et là il y a même peut-être dans des
sacrifices de dames encore qui se
calcule
prend des cartes alors ça marche
peut-être pas du tout mais ça se calcule
moi
ça marche peut-être pas bon ça marche
c'est sûr que ça marche pas mais
cavalier F3 si tu prends attends
oui
mais moi j'avais le perpète dans ma je
t'ai dit moi j'ai vu le perpète
moi j'avais vu le perpète
comme ça d'ailleurs
non mais ça marche pas ça
c'est très joli ça fait à chaque double
et c'est maths le fou des fois la tour
des fondateur on fait chaque double et
si je fais un coup il y a juste un seul
échec et ben je mets le pion devant et
hop plus rien
de marcher pour les Noirs ici donc il
est des fougères
tu fais quoi
[Musique]
tu seras plus ou moins tranquille je
pense
[Musique]
deux parties d'affilée ça va être
compliqué dame 5 ça va être compliqué
chacun va les prendre à 5 je crois
on peut manger tout simplement
oui en plus tu as pas de la découverte
parce que sur ça je prends là puis je
prends la
n'hésitez pas
à essayer des choses on est là pour
analyser toute façon s'il y a des
parties que vous voulez voir des parties
que vous voulez voir ou des ou même
proposer des choses ou demander des
questions vraiment n'hésitez pas on est
là pour pour vous aider aussi donc nous
aussi on essaie de comprendre en même
temps pour nous c'est pas évident tous
les jours non plus mais
mais on est là pour ça donc n'hésitez
pas
du matériel pour la qualité mais
aujourd'hui nous
dire tu as vu qu'il a il s'est mis tout
rouge avec son avec son petit pseudo là
encore une fois
donc le petit problème
lequel non pour l'instant j'ai pas eu de
problème de j'avais un bug là avec avec
Google Chrome écoute j'ai rien fait et
puis et puis autant que j'ai pas buggé
on ne parle pas de ce bugger mais bon
je me doute bien salut est-ce que tu
pensais à nos problèmes
alors du coup soyons sérieux
alors moi j'ai tout noté
favoris j'ai un pari en cours avec avec
Kevin et je suis pas bien je suis pas
bien du tout j'ai parié digne premier
car Hassan 2e
avait perdu
mais lui il a mis Carson premier digne
de 2e donc bon
là bon
je l'ai mis trois
fois cette fois huit fois car scène il a
gagné 8 fois le tournoi je crois
car wanna qu'il a gagné deux fois à
rognan qu'il a gagné quatre fois
et il a fait cinq fois deuxième
clairement était largement favoris mais
la configuration là ça donne envie de
mettre une pièce sur guéri qui brise la
maladie qui emporte là il fait un super
tournoi il a battu 47 ans plus alors
qu'il le jouera plus tu vois j'ai quatre
je vois la caméra était joué ce tout G4
et elle a l'air assez confiant enfin
confiant il est très sérieux
c'est un joueur qui vraiment donne tout
à chaque partie il est jeune il a 18 ans
le dernier ce genre de parier sur un
dernier on a mis par rame tous les deux
mais
après c'est remplaçant de dernière
minute donc c'est le mec qui arrive
en fait
tout le monde peut être dernier si tu
veux dans ce tournoi avant quasiment
tout le monde mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
pas mal de jeunes qui pour qui ça va
être difficile tu vois mais
mais bon ouais moi j'ai mis par âme
mais lui aussi d'ailleurs on verra bien
de toute façon
on verra bien alors est-ce qu'on fait un
petit tour sur les parties de manière
générale en karting ça peut être dur
après fouger 4
il va peut-être racheter
de suite bon on est très loin mais
je pense qu'il est en vrai danger ici le
fait que fougère je pense ça me coupe
vraiment déterminant que toutes les
tactiques marche on dirait en faveur de
cette Europe parce que si gardien il est
obligé de jouer un coup comme cavalier
au programme
pour faire tout ça c'est clairement pas
la rentabilité quoi donc
si c'est pour jouer ça
marche pas qu'on a déjà on a déjà
répondu juste au dessus de chat faut
prendre S6 il y a des Français 6 ne pas
oublier que en fait et ben il y a un
petit match du couloir derrière
donc c'est c'est compliqué cavalier 5
d'un point de V5 tout tout à l'heure de
de perdre
et sur ici on a dit qu'il y a des cartes
et ben j'ai Caval à prendre des quatre
on s'en fout du vis-à-vis parce qu'on a
un joli cavalier prend F3 celui d'un
tour des maths
c'est dur pour pour musicien
on verra on verra comment ça va évoluer
alors
petit Prague qui a réussi à changer des
pièces qui a une position assez légale
ici je pense que c'est juste position
simple qui va bientôt faire bientôt qui
dirige en tout cas vers la nul je pense
déjà faut savoir qui détient la plus
longue série d'invincibilité en
classique c'est combien 120 et quelques
je crois
ouais un truc comme ça
partie de suite sans perdre en partie
lente
donc c'est récent il avait fini par
perdre je crois que c'était il me semble
[Musique]
il a reperdu depuis mais ouais ça reste
évidemment il a perdu avant-hier déjà et
ça reste
hyper rare pour qu'on perde tout dans le
même tournoi c'est
assez hallucinant sachant qu'ils ont
voilà déjà arrivé
récemment mais ce qui est d'autant plus
hallucinant c'est que car en scène
ben il a 100 enfin il avait 120 parties
à peu près sans défaite
mais il joue pas contre des plots quoi
125 joue contre le top niveau pour le
top 10 tout le temps et avoir 125
parties sans défaite c'est hallucinant
quand à ce niveau-là
la force
pour cette précision on comprend mieux
pourquoi il a perdu quoi
c'est mérité
plus qu'une mérité
à tout prix casser cette diagonale en
tout cas créer des thèmes mais surtout
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est marrant ça
mime moi je regarde un coup un peu
bizarre mais parce que je suis un je
suis un peu comme ça mais B5
ce que je propose mais
regardez en fait
comment moi je calcule
l'idée c'est qu'on a compris que s'il
fout partait de la diagonale et ben on
peut faire la chatte on gagne une pièce
d'accord avec foulard et je crois parce
que le fou va clouer le point F2 et
qu'on va réussir à manger le pion enfin
le fou j'ai 3
du coup moi je vois bs5 et c'est
peut-être du coup
un mauvais coup mais en fait l'idée
c'est que surtout prend des cinq bah
j'ai de nouveau H4 suivi de G3 qui
peut-être peut gagner une pièce et
surtout prends mes 5 je pensais à du
coup à fou à 6 suivi de quand on bouge
faire [ __ ]
et derrière imaginons je veux un coup
juste pour voir ça ça et de nouveau H4
suivi du 3 du coup mon idée de dessin
qu'elle est fascinée
mais
non non mais bon c'est tu vois le thème
c'est clairement de virer ce fou donc là
il a fait J5
ou prendre un vide j'en sais rien mais
tu me donnes tout
à la place
ça va parce que là par exemple même si
tu pouvais même pas manger des six c'est
pas si simple quand même ok bon j'adore
mais dans l'idée de délier ce fou donc
il y a eu des cinq
et si on des cinq fouilles en dessin
alors pourquoi la GDF5
il veut pardon ouvrir la colonne
c'est ça
champion je prends cavalier gratuit et
sur fou prendre il a mangé ici en se
disant que quand il prend là je prends
là donc c'est la partie à la fin il
mange aussi G6 et après prise du coup et
ben il a mangé G4 et donc le renard qui
est quand même assez ouverts
j'aime pas trop la potion de Marvel
camélia qui joue pas le roi qui
complètement ouvert alors que le bras
blanc de son côté il est il est ultra
bien
A4 est faible et J6 sont aussi faible en
fait tous les pions noirs sont faibles
même les finales sont très très bas
parce que même si plus tard je perds le
pion après on prend puis on prend là
jusqu'à
absolument tout en prison donc
je j'aime beaucoup la pollution en tout
cas de grigasie et je pense qu'il y ait
il va pouvoir peut-être
la coller à Digne
c'est possible imagine si on a 45 et
digne qui perdent tous les deux en même
temps en deux parties de suite
et là on voit ben c'est contre les
jeunes c'est contre irrégasi
c'est contre Prague c'était contre
un scénario vraiment plausible au vu de
complètement complètement
troisième coup la position reste
compliquée
mais derrière c'est son adversaire qui a
pris l'initiative
ça peut mal tourner pour qu'un scène
on va on va regarder
bon un peu comme tout à l'heure je pense
une position qui a l'air quand même
assez assez égal
ils ont pas déjà
enlever des fours en mangeant des pions
ils vont se retrouver dans une finale de
Tours à 4 contre 4 un truc comme ça ça
va faire nul
de vente forest
qui a sacrifié sa dame
alors à deux
c'est une partie complètement fin depuis
le début déjà
attendu
en tout cas il semblerait qu'il soit
trompé quelque part dans sa prépa parce
que par Rama sacrifier une pièce et
obtenu une très très bonne position il
n'y a pas forcément été hyper précis
derrière et ben tout reste a rendu la
pièce
la position des blancs restait favorable
mais apparemment depuis un sacrifice de
dames donc on va voir comment on en est
arrivé là
par ici
donc
il laisse la dame
je réfléchis
comment je défends
c'est peut-être un coup pour fermer
la caméra sur les joueurs
on pouvait pas le faire tu peux montrer
tout quand même avant pourquoi on
pouvait pas faire trop à deux juste
qu'il y avait du temps
important ça peut faire marcher de
tactique
donc
empêcher ton bain qui passe assez
logique et surtout à 6 peut-être qu'on
peut faire tout reprendre à deux
maintenant qu'à Michel shining on va
voir et rentre dans le fou mais au moins
on aura moins l'espoir
que je pensais tu reprends à deux
donc
trois j'en sais rien
et au niveau matériel c'est tout
cavalier contre dame
donc c'est l'art quand même bien pour
les blancs
effectivement
ça va pas du tout raciste donc du coup
ça existe de dames alors quand même
pas forcément hyper convaincant mais du
coup est-ce qu'il était forcé de donner
la dame
son est pas bon je sais pas dans le chat
horrible on t'entend pas pour l'instant
on n'a pas eu de problème on a trois
heures de live on a eu zéro problème
est-ce que c'est voilà pour tout le
monde parce que c'est juste Roro qui a
un problème de son
est bon mais moi aussi c'est de mon côté
c'est bon aussi
que tu changes de haut-parleur
[Musique]
ou d'écouteurs je ne sais pas mais je
pense que
je parle pas juste à côté mais j'ai un
micro
après je dépends du son de ce stuff vu
que
c'est lui qui gère
mais ok moi ça a l'air d'aller pour tout
le monde yes merci en tout cas
j'aime bien les morts
que j'ai des cases pour m'enfuir
je fais tout droit pour vous ramener ma
tour peut-être en G3 à l'attaque
il va falloir que je la donne
peut-être plutôt je pense qu'il avait ça
fait quelques coups qu'il avait anticipé
de donner la dame non
ça fait peur quand même
on peut même faire un tour prend
cavalier chaque et maintenant j'ai 7 ans
ils ont un pion de plus qui va Adam donc
forcément que les Blancs ont de
l'attaque pour
ok ok
je comprends pas
du tout humain ça comme variante
ça paraît vraiment tu laisses tomber un
tu sacrifié une pièce
et maintenant tu as plus échec parce que
j'ai le droit F2 ok là c'est un truc
c'est
introuvable
c'était en train de chercher des
à ce truc qui est bien donc tu vas pas
chercher quelque chose de complètement
irrationnelle alors que tu es une
variante qui est très satisfaisante en
fait
et là ça va quand même bien pour les
blancs on va être dans le fameux débat
la forteresse en fait je pense ça va
être ça parce que les Noirs vont faire
une forteresse ou pas
il va essayer un affreux F3 priori
on peut mettre le cavalier devant ou
mettre le feu devant la tour devant mais
moi je vais tout manger et faire mat on
peut tout suicider donc on sera tout
mangé
il apporterait c'est narcos ici c'est
pas une question de niveau en fait la
forteresse ça existe clairement
peu importe le vélo c'est la position
qui fait que c'est une forteresse ou non
si tu peux pas passer tu peux pas passer
que tu sois placé 1000 et l'eau ou 2800
alors après c'était classé Milo il y a
plus de chances qu'il y a des erreurs et
donc la forteresse cède mais il y a eu
des exemples même comique et en plus
haut niveau par exemple c'était je crois
ce tournoi tata style il y a quelques
années c'était Guiri
dans la position finale en fait
tu coupes
ta connexion
c'est bon je te renvoie je peux je
t'entends
un petit problème
je sais pas ouais tu as coupé pendant
quelques secondes mais c'est bon
je parlais des forteresses je disais que
oui une question de niveau de Hello quel
que soit le hello il peut y avoir des
forteresses et que derrière à pas si
longtemps je crois que c'était au tata
style il y avait une forteresse
guilliche en clan c'était assez comique
pensons qu'il était perdu parce qu'il
avait un fou de moi dans une finale mais
il est très peu de matériel était très
réduit sauf qu'en réalité il avait une
forteresse il a abandonné dans une
position c'était nul il avait juste à
faire des coups droits on allait retour
sur la même case c'était nul et il
abandonné parce qu'il a pas compris que
c'était une forteresse
il a même pas chercher
parce qu'il a primoine
c'était aux Olympiades je crois et
il arrive plein de choses
alors du coup rapidement
voir s'il y a des parties qui ont un
petit peu bougé
Guiri il se passe pas grand chose pour
l'instant on peut aller voir guéri hein
pas du tout regardé à part au tout début
l'ouverture à la grande fête
Google
il y a un camp qu'un avantage matériel
clairement conséquent par exemple une
dame contre une tour à un pion mais
malgré l'avantage matériel c'est
impossible de transformer en victoire
c'est impossible de passer il y a la
réponse aussi au premier degré degrés
soleil c'est-à-dire que malgré les
avantages matériels tu vas réussir à
faire un blocus et ben le camp
une tour en plus un cavalier on défense
contre une dame à la dame elle va pas
tout seul elle va pas suffire pour
gagner
oui aussi une partie un exemple
alors la caméra de Google contre rapport
on a toujours une finale même si la
position
un petit peu plus compliqué par exemple
que la partie
de de Prague entre guéri
alors on va voir rapidement ce qui s'est
passé donc on a vraiment c'est le fou 6
et cahier donc les joueurs vraiment un
jour pour empêcher les pièces d'aller en
C4 on en a parlé tout à l'heure
foudez 5 à 4 E6 on va changer les pièces
et on mange depuis Angers pour garder le
cavalier sur son saccase là donc en plus
on ramène un pion vers le centre ça peut
être sympa plus tard pour pousser ses
petits pions au centre
fautifs tomber il faut à 3 pour gagner
la colonne après ton retour il y aura
autant et c'est les Noirs maintenant qui
vont rentrer sur sur la case C2 avec
leur tournoi le tour des un et du coup
bah maintenant on aurait pu voir un coup
comme tour des deux avec une
infiltration
détour sur la seconde rangée pour le
noir donc faut effectuer à 3 c'est
vraiment un
thème qui est assez standard dans
beaucoup de pollution pour gagner la
colonne quoi on vient la tour et on me
laisse passer avec la mienne
qui avance
et H1 donc positionne qui est assez
équilibré j'ai envie de dire des choses
encore peut-être un petit tour
torcer un ramener le roi vers eux
pour essayer de fixer le plan HS c'est
la double tranchant parce que notre
florragie
[Musique]
H7 un jour le roi noir s'en va un option
sera au bord de la dame donc c'est
toujours une question
intéressante à se poser ici
je pense que cette partie on va attendre
on va commencer à se décante de joueurs
qui sont la dernière position du tournoi
bientôt on va retourner là où c'est
chaud est-ce que carlossen se touche il
a il a trouvé une solution alors il a vu
et
du coup
ça dépend des deux et c'est le seul coup
on avait dit parce qu'avec tout à
l'heure faut qu'on se perdez aussi donc
le seul coup c'est cavaler et du coup
tourner a été le j'aime beaucoup ce coup
tourner
la dernière tour restante des blancs et
donc là la qualité elle va d'autant plus
parler parce que les noirs sont les
seuls à avoir une tour donc les seuls à
avoir une pièce qui se déplacent mais il
y a les dames encore mais
horizontal et vertical
et du coup quand on a deux tours contre
une bon les blancs ils ont encore leur
tour qui fait qui fait des choses là
on sent que l'attaque
et maintenant ils ont un avantage
matériel il y a une qualité d'avance
pour un pion
il va devoir lutter ici pour ne pas
perdre je pense ouais exactement
désolé pour tout ce petit truc là qui
peuvent arriver quand toutes les caméras
arrivent c'est mon petit Obs qui fait
des caprices à chaque fois
au niveau du temps il y a une égalité
parfaite 23 minutes ils ont 23 jouer
après la position rentrer un petit à
petit de se simplifier même s'il reste
pas mal d'intrigues encore
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les Blancs
imaginé cette position quand il a
sacrifié la qualité
il y a seulement six coups se retrouver
comme ça et très content là c'est pas du
tout un bon signe pour lui
mais en gros danger alors qu'est-ce qui
va jouer je sais pas ce qui va jouer là
il a l'air complètement foutu en fait
ce qui est important c'est d'être
capable de dire ok ça a mal tourné
maintenant je change d'objectif je joue
pour je vais essayer de sauver les
meubles quoi de jouer pour la nul
j'ai réussi à basculer dans sa tête
et
penser comme ça déjà sa première chose à
faire je pense
de particules oui c'est sûr qu'on pourra
dire qu'il est pas forcément grande
forme il avait jusque-là fait un bon
début de tournoi
avec une victoire convaincante notamment
mais
là il est en danger alors sur Dame des
deux menace fous des 6 à quoi bonne
question
a l'air de résoudre les deux problèmes
d'un coup
de 2900 est très mal parti effectivement
dans des bois
ça en terme de vélo il est plutôt hyper
quand même plutôt des points globalement
c'est dur en même temps dès qu'il fait
des nuls dans ce temps-là il perd des
cons
c'est pas quel est le score théorique de
quinzaine pour ne pas perdre de points
et c'est mal parti
pour tous il vient de faire aujourd'hui
voilà je pense que c'est cette position
elle est quasiment terminée en fait tu
vois pas il y a plus de tours il y a
plus moyen de mettre la pression sur le
pion pour la qualité il y a quand même
la paire de fou ouais ok mais ça m'a
l'air vraiment
à part grosse boulette d'Abdou c'est sûr
que tu en as plus du tout
ok 9 / 13 je voulais faire déjà
ah ouais non mais c'est clair
c'est 5 victoires entre 0
[Musique]
qui nous sera très loin
il est capable aussi de gagner beaucoup
de parties d'un film
à l'endroit après encore perdu
je pense c'est plutôt une bonne décision
il va ramener j'imagine peut-être en G2
en défense de son roi ouais enfin je
trouve
essayer de venir sur des cases sympas
etc mais ça c'est l'impression de rêve
de carsel c'est mettre le fond en jeu le
cavalier ici voilà ça c'est la potion de
rêve mais du coup
ça va pas être si simple je pense votre
Abdou va est-ce que tu apprécies pour
empêcher un peu ça
après ça reste pas simple encore comme
tu l'as dit il y a un bien pour la
qualité
on peut
assez facilement c'est peut-être un peu
exagéré mais pas loin se créer un pion
passé avec les noirs et faire valoir du
coup la qualité alors que le 4 les 4
pions des Blancs étaient un peu bloqué
par les deux pions des Noirs même si ils
vont être faibles et tapés par le foot
casse blanche
imaginons que les Noirs vous amènent un
four en G6 pour verrouiller leur pion
d'après on va essayer de pousser
de pousser à la dame ça implique
d'échanger
pour être honnête avec toi
on fait un petit tour
alors du coup
on a on a Prague et qui
met la pression quand même
oui mais bon comment tu bah en fait il y
a quand même deux faiblesses
trois tours tours
j'y crois pas du tout
et ça soit suffisant
pour l'instant F3 c'est difficile à
faire à cause de la 4
peut-être
[Musique]
moi je suis actif
oui mais tu bougeras pas grand-chose
quoi
du bon côté de la nul mais je vois pas
pour moi
en tout cas il y a des chances de
pressing mais ok il y a la nul reste
quand même un résultat est plus logique
mais il y a quand même deux petites
faiblesses là on voit trois qu'on peut
peut-être
essayer de presser mais ok il y a quand
même il y a quand même
de grandes chances
très probable
tu peux continuer le tour du stade
peut-être voir les esquives justement où
on se disait que ça risque de bientôt
finir comme Caro à Dassault ça sentait
aussi bien OK
plein de coups c'est sympa pour
le numéro chinois et franchement trois
difficile hein j'ai l'impression pour
l'instant pour dire
un peu les pièces
mais bon ça je pense que les joueurs
vont bientôt s'accorder sur la
il y a le plus pour les noirs que du mal
à bouger
ça c'est une menace l'idée alors je suis
un coup un coup pourri juste pour juste
pour voir mon petit truc tout F6 l'idée
en fait c'est que sur tout reprendre en
tout cas j'obstrue le fou et surtout
prends un F6 si on prend un FC je menace
mate et je pense que un des gains pour
les Noirs ça va être de mettre une tour
de vent
on va essayer de
attendez
absolument pas c'était l'idée que
j'avais ok
3D 8 est une idée
d'une façon ou d'une autre
plus pour les Noirs mais les Noirs ont
du mal à bouger
il y a quand même des réseaux de maths
tour échec il faut F6 c'est c'est pas si
facile que ça t'arrive de faire mieux là
je pense
ça sa petite pause avec de la dame
d'avance
et du coup ça ça peut être pas mal pour
les blancs parce que du coup au niveau
de la forteresse comme tu en parlait
tout à l'heure
passer c'est quand même pas la même tu
vois généralement une forteresse ça
pourrait peut-être marcher s'il y a
toujours été pas là par exemple
je ne sais pas où peut-être dans trois
et on peut imaginer plus tard ben le fou
qui revient en E2 le pion qui est rentré
4 et progresser au fur et à mesure comme
ça
pas une bonne partie quand même je
trouve puisqu'il se trompe dans
l'ouverture il revient un peu il force
son sacrifice de dames perd de prendre
des très bonnes décisions cette partie
je sais pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il a déjà vendangé
un peu parfois par amour donc c'est pour
ça que
des pointillés à sa future victoire mais
la position pour
un moment qu'on a pas vu cette partie
je vais vous mettre une caméra sur sur
excitant même position mais peut-être
que ça a pris une tournure plus
intéressante
je suis désolé
donc on avait dit Damas 5 pour faire
Damas 2 et après Caval et G3 du coup il
y a eu P4 ce qui est un coup intéressant
là on avait parlé de tout liquider on a
parlé de manger de manger et de
d'échanger les pièces et c'est de faire
news mais BK je trouve ça assez
intéressant
pour en fait essayer de faire Tam à deux
en fait rentrer par là et le pion B3 qui
pète une faiblesse sur le long terme
mais aussi le foot 15 blanche qui
maintenant est enfermé derrière la
structure
qui est une très mauvaise pièce quoi ici
à part le fouet encore
pas bien alors que cavalier peuvent plus
manœuvrer quand les positions est
ouvertes le focaliser de loin donc c'est
pour ça que les fonctions meilleures
dans les positions ouvertes donc B4 a
été joué cavalier E1 cavalier C5 la
casse pour le cavale tour dehors de
cavalier en 17
ici pour défendre le pion et après en
échange et ben tu vois quand même à
manger du Pione pour ouvrir du coup son
fou ici ok ça donne des perspectives
d'attaque au blanc maintenant sur le roi
donc
[Musique]
contre le bon foot théorique des
baignoirs
[Musique]
c'est la position actuelle ok ça a
plutôt bien tourné en faveur d'aronia
non qui maintenant a quand même
plusieurs pièces braquées sur le roi les
fous noirs sont quand même passifs
malgré tout si j'ai changé les dames
c'est le pion bécane qui se retrouvait
extrêmement faible donc c'est même pas
un accomplissement
ça va être compliqué
un rêve serait de mettre le fou ici
il a changé peut-être même les fous avec
fougères donc souvent d'ailleurs il y a
des idées de cavaliers bougent pour que
j'ai fougé 5 pour changer les mauvais
fous et après
chaque camp veut se libérer de se
débarrasser
blanc c'est le fou S5 et le bon fou des
Noirs donc c'est logique et le mauvais
fou des Noirs c'est le fouet contre le
foot
donc
voilà on va voir un peu ce qui se passe
OK et la suite de de ce petit tour c'est
goût cash rapport donc là on a eu le
pion qui a avancé quand même
c'est trop à 6 h 5 donc on avait parlé
d'âge 6 pour avoir une belle carte en
gs5 éventuellement le roi qui peut être
passif aussi en
G8 ou F8 après prise tour B3 et du coup
on va voir si on peut essayer d'attaquer
au final le petit pion ici donc il y a
eu c'est 5 ici de jouer qui est
intéressant pour manger le foodcase
ici et du coup j'ai un petit avantage
avec le blanc parce que du coup j'ai les
tours qui peuvent rentrer sur les sur la
colonne
et que en cas de finale ben tu vois un
jour si elle la tour bouge je pense lui
échec ton là qui peut être sympa
mais tu vois quand tu sais toujours
contre pour deux résultats c'est
intéressant
ok donc à voir comment rapporte
est-ce que tu fais un kit pose Samy ça
fait trois heures et quelques qu'on est
ici on n'a pas encore pas pris de pause
effectivement
à la fois les hypnotes c'est le bon
moment tu as raison avant de avant de
d'arriver au 40e
ça marche on fait une petite pause on
revient d'ici 5 minutes
pour voir ce deck note tout ça donc à
tout de suite
c'est pas la bonne scène à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes de retour avec sa
toux notamment
micro objet
au début j'avais oublié mais
mais je l'ai remis
notamment
c'était fort la musique j'ai même pas
écouté
et donc on en était à 45 grande danger
avec les Blancs
donc peut-être une nouvelle ronde avec
les deux favoris au tapis qu'on va
essayer de découvrir ensemble pendant
ces hypnotes comment ça se passe alors
est-ce qu'il y a eu des cours on
commence par 15 16 il y a eu la nul que
tu nous avais proposé tu l'avais tu
l'avais dit hein
ce qui s'est passé hein ça fait nul donc
Caravana so bon c'était pas très très
c'est pas une grosse surprise j'ai envie
de dire c'est nul
donc on peut l'enlever du coup comment
c'est pas leur première nulle ensemble
et sûrement pas leur dernière non plus
sûrement donc je te propose
je vais vous mettre la caméra de Carlson
on va voir un peu ce qui s'est passé il
y a eu le temps
de voir les coups donc
ici et sur H3
il faut
et chèque
j'arrive pas à faire des flèches et sur
rouage j'aurais damage de et chacun
rouge après la position est compliquée
La Traviata la barre d'évaluation depuis
le dernier qui veut venir ici et essayer
de virer un petit peu les pièces noires
j'imagine que les Noirs arrivent vite
peut-être qu'il y a des tours D1 qui
peuvent arriver
avoir un temps
tu cherches la caméra là où je connais
tu as raison pour laquelle c'est pas bon
d'un point de vue humain Dame des cas
c'est quand même une case centrale qui a
du sens mais en fait à ce qui fait avec
Dame là là ils veulent manger à Hachette
et la raison de toute façon parce que
parce que
il a été de moi il veut essayer
d'attaquer les pions là-haut
mais la première pièce devant son roi
donc ça peut créer quand même des tentes
alors c'est peut-être le danger que voir
l'ordinateur on va voir table des quatre
il y a eu le temps des vies qui a l'air
très logique pour des villes dommage 4
il va en H4
moi je fais tourner
ainsi cavalier bouge un peu mieux avoir
du du Fou B5 avec des clouages c'est
compliqué une position nature
ok intéressant et que se passe-t-il sur
d'apprendre du coup est-ce que c'est une
idée
qui va défendre
qui peut être
très intéressant dans la grande
diagonale
c'est loin d'être fini cette partie
c'est tout enfin même personne qui va se
battre donc ils ont encore en plus ils
ont peu de temps la pendule je te
rappelle la cadence c'est 1h40 pour 40
coups avec
50 minutes au 40e coup pour 20 coups et
du coup au 60e ils ont encore 15 minutes
pour finir la partie avec à chaque fois
15 minutes avant 30 secondes pour chaque
coup et du coup
dans cette position bah on va cartienne
il a 8 minutes à la pendule entre 12
pour jouer encore 16 coups donc c'est
pas évident il faut jouer quand même un
petit peu vite la position est pas
facile à gérer avec peu de temps ça
serait mal venu de faire des erreurs en
direct note donc
pas facile quoi en tout cas pour les
deux joueurs qui peuvent se tromper
encore une fois même si le matin est
réduit c'est une position qui est très
compliqué à jouer parce qu'il y a un
déséquilibre matériel
alors on voit que peut-être les blancs
vont avoir un pion passé de leur côté
les noirs de l'autre donc c'est très
facile de faire des erreurs en fait
on poursuit notre petit tour yes alors
que du coup Prague on avait annoncé une
finale avec un léger pressing très léger
des blancs avec ton B6 on pouvait
espérer peut-être un jour attaquer là
mais comme disait Sami à Sami il était
un peu optimiste pour les Noirs il
disait que les gens arrivaient aussi
attaquer les faiblesses des blancs et en
fait ben ça se montre comme ça tu auras
un roi F7 et puis le roi qui se balade
en G6 qui vient en F3 qui va venir en
Détroit et en fait tout simplement voilà
défense active donc
la position ici elle a l'air quand même
assez
même si j'ai trois quand même mine de
rien n'empêche pour R4
là je me lasse 3g2 qui va virer la tour
pourra pas venir ici sur G4 voir si je
peux pas jouer à
5 bon je sais pas qui ça
[Musique]
va faire drôle tout mais c'est pas de
nous survendre ton trail non mais bon en
fait moi j'ai une seule faiblesse tu en
as deux donc
j'essaie de voir mais mais ça risque de
faire nul ouais donc là ils sont 31e
coups il y a encore 9 coups à jouer avec
12 minutes chacun
une position qui est quand même moins
compliqué que celle de Magnus par
exemple
c'est une position très compliqué donc
du coup vu qu'on va rester un peu un
petit peu plus de temps je vais vous
montrer la caméra de peut-être un peu
tourner alors une position complexe mais
on voit qu'il y a cette porte qui arrive
mais peut-être alors qu'à certainement
j'ai un pion qui se retrouve un peu pris
au piège maintenant
peut-être que ça va impliquer un
sacrifice de qualité sur B6 un moment
donné à moins que les Blancs ne jouent
n'arrive à pousser leurs clients au C5
mais ça paraît pas facile
digne qui a apparemment consolidé son
droit paraît moins faible que tout à
l'heure
cavalier F3 qui a laissé du coup faut B6
au noir donc le la tour en B7 qui est
qui est un peu mal placé
et le but c'est de défendre F2 en
fermant la colonne fresque
de une deux trois quatre pièces qui
attaquées ici
pour empêcher
du coup c'est 5
et tourbé 1 pour pour jeter de retour
mais si c'est une menace
je sais pas ça dépend pas mal aussi
garder la tension
est-ce que ce qu'on peut sacrifier ou
est-ce que ça sert à rien
à chaque fois ça c'est quand même
fourchette si je mets mon grand F1
c'est extrêmement dangereux donc on n'a
pas du tout envie de faire ça
du coup le pur il est pas vraiment en
prise maintenant mais un tour avec un
pied enfermé j'ai passé 5 comment est-ce
que je joue là il y a une pression sur
le pion ici il y a HK qui peut être une
idée à chaque fois
comment est-ce qu'on joue aussi
je sais pas si c'est bon la prise
concrètement ça a pas l'air simple
mais si
de comprendre
mais
à terme oui ça peut clairement être un
moyen d'aller chercher cette tourbe donc
position très compliqué il y a des
joueurs quand vous 10 minutes à peine
tout peut se passer ici c'est une
décision très dure à prendre un
pourriasis je commence à presque
préférer les Noirs en fait après tout ça
c'est moi qui qui menace des trucs même
pourquoi donc on a un point c'est
clairement des menaces
je pense
ça
plus que 11 minutes pour jouer 12 coups
5 quasiment 6
position est pas simple
ok alors on continue on voit est-ce que
est-ce que parram il a progressé ou pas
rame il a les blancs et ben il a l'air
d'être gagnant il a la dame pion pour
cavalier tour
l'option qui maintenant va commencer à
avancer
je pense que c'est un gars un gars assez
facile pour parrain blanc qui n'a pas
peur il pourra monter tranquillement
même souvent
compliqué de créer des ananas
assez facilement
j'ai l'impression pour irrigazi
il est bien par rame et oui ça serait sa
deuxième défaite
[Musique]
alors du coup
on a un
regard qui a balancé un F5 hein
OK
il veut ouvrir la position pour c'est
fou c'est tout à fait compréhensible
après tout revête il y a eu tout F1 donc
la prise ici n'intéressait pas
n'intéressait pas encore
à rognan pourquoi
je réfléchis
parce que ça permet d'avoir des pions
passés bien le côté il y a un blocus qui
va se faire sur le gaz noir et le fout
de case noir qui devient enfin qui passe
de mauvais ah bon en fait
c'est pour ça qu'il a pas appris pour
l'instant tout
donc
il faut prendre un F2 chez ligne oulala
on va aller voir on finit juste ça
croire et là on va du coup assister à
une prise ici
pour les blonds cette position
globalement
enclencher la marche avant avec C4 et D5
ça peut aller très vite
avec avec vous trois et peut-être c'est
5 c'est 6 ok après on s'en fout sur
l'âme sœur
c'est pas
c'est pas facile
on verra un petit peu plus tard si
concrétise qu'on retourne au cœur de
l'action c'est un fou prend F2 chez Ding
allez on va voir on va voir Ding il a
joué la balle qu'on disait qu'il avait
l'air très mauvaise
en pratique ça a l'air hyper dur
pour pour leur indien alors quasiment
foutu en fait non
F3 avec force
et là on menace tout reprendre
le cavalier donc ça ça
j'ai l'impression qu'il est en train de
perdre le fil dans le genre indien ouais
il fait pas une bonne partie il avait
faim il avait fait une partie
extrêmement intéressantes mais là ça
fait quelques coups qui qui nage un
petit peu là
depuis tu vois ça tourne s'est retrouvé
mal placé ensuite il a dû jouer par
rapport à ça et il a perdu
il a perdu un peu le fil ensuite j'ai
l'impression
pour l'instant cavalier
et surtout pour F3 il peut reprendre
avec la dame peut-être
sur la page 3 c'est ça
ça fait quoi
en tout cas ça a l'air ça a l'air
visuellement ça a l'air dur
roi H8 c'est pas le problème
100 100 100 100
et sur cavalier
etc ça va pas et si je mange maintenant
il y a plus mal du couloir
puis là j'ai deux pièces pour la tour
mais bon
là je peux changer pousser mon pion mais
bon c'est hyper compliqué tout ça
[Musique]
c'est pas possible ça gagne forcément et
c'est hyper frustrant si tu trouves
toujours une défense pour ton adversaire
que tu dis que lui-même il a peut-être
pas tout vu mais
instinctivement on se dit ça peut pas
aller en fait le roi il a pas assez de
défenseur il est tout seul
c'est pas sûr qu'il y a un gain direct
en tout cas
d'après la jauge non et nous elle a les
humains
répondre à la question de martialon
c'est pas trop pour aller réserves on
sait que le tata style il a vu des
sérieux
différents avec les organisateurs
d'une édition précédente et donc c'est
certainement pour ça qu'ils reviennent
pas ici après pourquoi il a pas joué par
exemple et rapide et Blitz pas du monde
ça c'est un peu
surprenants j'ai vu sur Twitter de trucs
complètement abracadabrantesque genre il
va arrêter les échecs pour se lancer
dans la mode
ok donc on va voir un peu ce qui se
passe dans l'autre partie là il leur
reste 4 minutes contre 6
non c'est le point chaud de toute façon
les deux parties
qui nous intéresse le plus là il est
mangé depuis un H7 il a laissé à deux
alors il se passe c'est quoi attends
donc du coup il échange des pièces
il enlève la paire de foubet
ici on va sortir le four quelque part
peut-être
clair et ça va être la course
ça va être la course le foot case noir
avec le pion h contre Ben le pion 1
il est presque aussi fort que la tour
quand même dans cette diagonale
vraiment la case promotion là-haut et
puis il y aura priori il y a pas trop de
problèmes sur case noire je pense pour
mater parce que je pourrais toujours
mettre mon fou devant me défendre ah
ouais c'est pas clair
à toute fin de la course ça peut être
utile aussi
à Saint-Grégoire c'est le moment parce
que là on sait que lui va arriver très
vite moi en plus j'ai plein de gain de
temps avec les Blancs genre j'ai dû
échec là pour gagner un temps pour
avancer le pion et puis en plus même
quand tu fais dames je tourne en fou qui
peut sacrifier donc c'est vraiment pas
simple franchement ça mit j'ai envie de
te dire que là je prends je pense que je
prends les blancs
il faut que je réfléchisse alors
est-ce que c'est grave ou pas ça alors
comme d'hab si tu manges tous les pions
ça peut être grave la caméra on voit que
sing comme tu dis pas plus
on va voir ce qui va se passer
pour pour cette session de Bullet là
cette enchaînement
je sais pas parce que
on va essayer la grande caméra
hop elle arrive
Iceman n'a pas gagné il est loin d'avoir
gagné il était même plutôt en grand
danger
elle a position maintenant un peu à
double tranchant oui
c'est un dingue
mais apparemment une dame dessin qui a
l'air d'être la seule défense on a vu on
peut remontrer rapidement peut-être
souffler prise perdre échec voilà et
chèque voilà
tout reprendre
là il y avait un truc très très joli
avec échec ici Damas 3 et foue1
extrêmement joli qui va venir
intercepter la tour la tour V1 et en
fait là je menace maths
enfin j'ai aussi fourchette et pas entre
et du coup la grosse grosse défense
c'est Dame des cinq échecs avec l'idée
que sur roi A8 ici non qu'est-ce qui
nous fait
pourquoi tu touches quoi c'était bien ok
là c'est bien
tout ça rien quoi
dans quoi je suis du coup l'idée après
échec c'est que maintenant je peux
manger et du coup la différence c'est
que sur échec ah il a fait grand dessin
la différence c'est que ce réchauffe là
damage 3 si je suis fou maintenant et
ben du coup il a le coup intermédiaire
fou E5 est très joli en fait qui fait
que sur
G8 et ben j'ai tout G7 échec etc et en
fait sur cavalier prend un 5 et ben j'ai
plus maths quand je mange là parce que
du coup
cavalier n'est plus ici quoi
donc là du coup il y a ça et puis j'ai
l'impression que les Noirs s'en sortent
un petit peu enfin les blancs se sentent
un petit peu donc
en vrai c'est trouvable je pense
que tu es tellement foutu attention
du coup si je prends là ça change rien
c'est la même
ça n'a rien changé par rapport à tout à
l'heure à sa perte de la même façon
c'est la même
du coup reste un échec alors je pense
[Musique]
qu'il arrive pas à récupérer la pièce là
on veut calculer
il faut prendre
il y a rien d'autre façon il y a une
menace de masse il va forcément jouer
rien à dire mais il réagit là quoi
il a dû voir tout ça ça veut dire
certainement quand il est rentré dans
cette variante donc
il avait certainement vu quoi mais
je pense pas quand j'en foutais jusque
là quoi ça c'est ça m'a l'air compliqué
il monte avec les flèches les Noirs
menacent à chaque fois d'aller mater
dans la colonne à choix par damage 2
soit par Da H4 donc le Fou vient en
diagonale attaque et la dame en
contrôlant sa case de pénétration pour
ma tête
et en fait alors à part si dim il trouve
une autre case peut-être pour sa dame
c'est possible oui qui trouve un autre
coup pour continuer
à toutes les pièces
subtil parce que la dame est venue en D5
maintenant elle est cool la Tour Eiffel
et c'est ce qui permet au fou d'aller en
C7 sans se faire manger par la tour
c'est un truc de fou quoi
c'est un truc de fou et là c'est là que
tu vois que franchement les échecs ça
peut être cruel parce que tu as
l'impression que tu es mate de partout
et tout tiens quoi
et je pense que tu vois on peut dire que
des fois dans la déchètes il y a une
part de chance quand même il fait que tu
as pas forcément tout contrôlé mais il
se trouve que quand tu vois rien qui
marche quoi ouais oui clairement ça
pourrait gagner honnêtement
qu'est-ce qui peut jouer d'autres est-ce
que dans l'autre position il peut nous
paraître peut-être avec la dame en FC
ou pas
1 2 non
ça fait que deux fois
niveau c'est beaucoup plus déterministe
ouais non c'est clair c'est hyper joli
hein
il a une autre case alors tu peux le
jouer s'il te plaît
parce que là il peut mettre sadama
ailleurs ou pas
bah je sais pas mais bon
en terme de matériel oui si l'échange
même sans les dames
qui vont s'échanger
si il faut faire un nul c'est la
meilleure couleur c'est juste incroyable
question il y a une pièce de plus en
fait c'est complètement incroyable
chez nous digne à une minute trente
et et Gazi il a 4 minutes chez nous il
reste encore 5 coups à jouer 6 pour Ding
donc 6 coups pour Ding a joué avec une
minute à la pendule ce qui va trouver un
coup pour continuer cavaluer
mais bon
en plus avec pendule c'est c'est
compliqué de se lancer dans un truc
comme ça avec comme Cavalo 3 tu vois
il a envie de jouer
sans qu'il a envie de jouer un coup ça
fait chier il est pas je pense qu'il est
un petit là
tu sens que
[Musique]
d'ordinateurs
troisième coup et là on peut pas dire
qu'ils ont fait nul à ranger parce que
tu vois que dit il est vraiment colère
pourquoi pas
ici là
en fait
un bel essai
tout marche pour
c'est pas possible il a une pièce de
plus il a 5 pièces sur le roi regardez
le roi il a pas une pièce autour de lui
c'est incroyable impression que enfin
la position
quand il rentrera pas il verra que c'est
nul en fait qu'il a pas il va arrêter la
pendule
pour voir un petit peu la réaction mais
c'est vrai que digne il a vraiment
il sent qu'il a raté quelque chose il
regrette
pas du coup absent
au lieu ok il se passe quoi sur Foot la
finale
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
énorme défense de l'Asie pour pour ne
pas perdre cette partie assez incroyable
qui a une finale dedans
qui est peut-être en train de retourner
Abdou alors ils sont eux aussi
du coup
donc là ils sont à un coup du du rajout
de temps après je vous remets une vue
normale
on pourra faire des briques après si
vous voulez mais pour l'instant vu qu'il
y a plus beaucoup de temps ça lui Kevin
ça se passe très bien merci on vient
d'insister à une nulle extrêmement
spectaculaire entre elle et gaziers et
diminueren
ah oui la défense d'erégasie mais
monstrueuse quoi absolument monstrueuse
comment on est arrivé là tout dans cette
finale de dames puisque avant alors
j'aurais voulu voir juste après ça
dérange pas parce qu'il nous reste plus
que deux coups avant d'arriver au 40e
attends la caméra qui est
va regarder à la place le fond bleu
du coup du coup OK dans deux coups si tu
veux on regarde un peu ce qui s'est
passé
avant le diagnotte parce que si il se
passe un truc pendant que notes on
pourra pas le voir malheureusement
[Musique]
à plus avancé
il y a toujours dans sa finale de Dame
des questions de perpétuelle à essayer
d'éviter
le bureau de Carcassonne et pas pas très
en retard non plus mais c'est très très
dur à évaluer ça pour les humains c'est
vachement c'est les positions où il y a
la plus grosse différence de niveau
entre les superordinateurs et les
meilleurs joueurs du monde d'ailleurs je
me rappelle la partie la partie ou Abdou
il avait battu 45 la partie rapide c'est
quand Abdou la question du monde de
rapides et ben c'était une finale de
dames pareil il avait un pion de plus
comme ça il avait réussi à gagner quoi
c'était impossible
à chaque fois
du coup tu en as deux
on va vouloir jouer à H5 H6
jouer F4 et ouvrir le roi blanc et si
jamais il arrive à ouvrir le roi blanc
et ben du coup il y aura plein de
carpettes toujours au cas où il pleut
des chèques aussi et du coup il arrivera
mieux à contrôler le pion h c'est un
coup assez intelligent je trouve F5
clairement et
il a 5 est-ce que je peux pas jouer
c'est possible on se retrouve dans une
finale stuff avec roi dame chez les
noirs et le pion B7 contre roi dame chez
les Blancs
objet d'ailleurs c'est ce que propose
c'est ce que propose à 12 à 3
franchement
le pion F5
qui viennent de recevoir
donc là on a 40e coup donc du coup on va
pouvoir voir ce qui s'est passé je vais
vous mettre là l'autre vue si vous
voulez je vous mettre la vue la vue
avec le grand échec qui est hop
pardon excusez-moi je fais un peu
n'importe je vous ai mis
la mauvaise vue
et la caméra je me suis tombé de caméra
aussi c'est pas la neuf
c'est la 6 bon temps pour moi
on jouait sans incrément là à chaque
couille à 30 secondes qui se rajoute
maintenant on est obligé de noter pour
le coup parce qu'on estime qu'avec les
30 secondes on a le temps de noter le
coup avant il y avait pas cette
incrément et les joueurs avaient le
droit d'arrêter de noter on disait moins
de 5 minutes à la pendule jusqu'au 40e
coup mais cette époque ça fait déjà
quelques années qu'elle allait
évoluerait
alors qu'est-ce qui est passé on va
revenir un petit peu tout à l'heure qui
avait droit
donc il a pas défendu F2
à échec dans l'échec
et beaucoup de jeux
donc il y a eu du coup
Dame des 5 dame 2 dames pardon qui
attaque la tour et chèque le fond en
l'air mais j'ai aussi ma tour en l'air
sacrifier la la qualité avec les noirs
pour essayer du coup de
gagner la finale depuis en fait c'est
une décision qui peut se comprendre bah
oui il enlève tout le contre-jeu de
l'adversaire
et du coup ben il joue avec son plus
OK
et là il y a quand même des chances de
nulle j'ai envie de dire ce que je
t'avais dit qu'on allait
se retrouver parce que à mon avis à un
moment donné le pion FG risque de
s'échanger donc on peut retrouver avec
cette finale de dame dame pion contre
dames
pas du tout avancé comme c'est le cas
je pense que ça fait mieux en plus le
droit de personnes est bien placé pour
ça généralement
d'un pion contre dinde pour faire nul il
faut être un il faut mettre le roi sur
un sur un côté
normalement ça devrait être OK
non il y a pas de français cette année
ni firme ni
maxi mais on avait aussi un petit
produit mort il dit qu'il avait fait le
challenger mais cette année il est pas
là non plus alors oui je suis riche en
terme aujourd'hui Kevin assez ça bug un
petit peu à chaque fois que je veux la
changer ça me met un truc bizarre mais
ça va j'ai beaucoup plus de caméra
qu'avec toi et qu'avec Mathieu il faut
dire qu'aujourd'hui il soit Amsterdam et
du coup du coup ben ça va tout je sais
pas ça marche bien
[Musique]
et ça se bat on va revenir là il y a eu
échec qui pousse G4
et puis ça va ça va gagner je pense là
je place de manger ici
j'ai toujours une menace pour essayer de
changer les pièces j'ai une dame à un
pion de plus je pense à partir va se
finir par très très peu de coups Samy
[Musique]
un peu ce qui se passe
on a du coup
en plus pour pour les blancs
il y a eu le tour prend et il y a eu F4
qui est logique
avec Dame des deux donc on replace les
pièces il y a des fois les menaces de
manger 6 donc là il y a eu H5 tu vois il
a eu tellement peur de faut prendre H6
qu'il soit H5
fou G5 H4
une petite menace
et taper du coup sur sur 3 donc
intéressant même si tout F3 arrive ici
on s'en fout peut-être juste un
peut-être qu'on s'en fout juste de ce
fou ici peut-être un du G5 qui peut
enfermer de fou derrière
Jordan bouge par exemple G5 et ça qui
peut gagner simplement en fait
OK
bonne soirée à toi et du coup bah à
demain Kevin demain demain c'est toi qui
reviens
exactement
ok donc on devrait peut-être avoir une
histoire d'Harmonia donc en tout cas une
finale avec un trou de plus la
clairement pousser d'un Maxou de l'eau
qui devrait gagner
praguer ça devrait faire nul
et Carlson mais normalement ça devrait
être nul aussi même si peut-être
souffrir il nous reste dans le goût
cache rapport on n'a pas on s'est arrêté
à cavaler ses 5 tout à l'heure
il y a une répétition j'ai l'impression
il y avait cavaler ses 5
tours
[Musique]
qui a infusé la répétition et logique
donc ouais fin G5
fu au 3
E5 ici
donc le 5 liens c'est que le pion parte
pour venir plus tard manger du coup la
pièce en CS5
qui avait baisser
bouge il revient
donc
elle se bat pour sauver la nuit
clairement
pour faire un nul Google
je pense qu'elle revient qui va gagner
aussi
ok
en plus pour Prague
mais je suis un peu bloqué peut-être si
je bouge le pion je perd lui
le voit blanc il est un petit peu
inactif tu vois c'est le roi là il y a
peut-être du Tour à deux qui peut
arriver pour empêcher le droit de bouger
quand même au final
c'est un peu même des fois être
dangereux pour pour les blancs il faut
qu'il s'occupe du piondi quoi en fait il
peut pas se permettre ils arrivent à
faire par exemple je sais pas ça ça
écoute je peux commencer à pousser mon
pion quoi tu vois donc c'est clairement
pas simple
donc avoir un peu ce qui se passe
clairement pas simple ok mais bon ça a
quand même je pense que résultat le plus
proche lui aussi c'est nul donc on a pas
mal de nuls Carsen il faut qu'il prouve
et qui fasse nul on a PRAC qui va priori
peut-être faire nul Google
qui va gagner et aaronium qui pousse un
petit peu
une posture et donc un scène fait voir
si ça a évolue un petit peu cette finale
de dame alors comme ça on est comme ça
qui est un joueur ouzbek il a 18 ans
c'est ça comment
il a 18 ans
qui a été champion du monde de rapides
déjà
pas mon dernier mais d'avant donc un
joueur extrêmement prometteur
et déjà tiens mieux que tenir la dragée
dans cette partie avec les noirs
devrait peut-être s'en sortir mais bon
c'est vraiment toujours dur c'est final
dedans moi je trouve en pratique
c'est c'est pas facile c'est pas facile
effectivement
il y a toujours des problèmes pratiques
tu vois par exemple échanger les
échanger les dames par exemple ça peut
être compliqué tu vois le roi de Cassin
ici il est en géant et il faut défendre
le pion et par an sur un coup comme moi
H2 faire attention de son transposition
tu vois
et un jour par exemple passe moi reste
bien sur une case blanche sur un dame 4
échec tu vois et vraiment faire
attention à tout quoi et
donc c'est c'est une torture ça va être
une torture moi je peux imaginer un
échec roi là et peut-être dame 5
pour essayer de venir son case noire
défendre lui menacer un peu ça tu vois
parce que là tu as un plan
je pense que ça peut durer très
longtemps cette partie c'est tout enfin
à part si il arrive à forcer un
perpétuel d'une façon d'une autre mais
de tenir enfin de durer en tout cas
pendant
un bon petit moment
que je ne suivrai pas avec toi
vous savez que depuis le début
j'ai eu quasiment tous les streams où je
terminais tout seul
et chaque fois m'abandonne c'est
toujours le dernier survivant
là je pense qu'en plus tu en as pour un
petit moment
ça serait avec avec grand plaisir et
d'ailleurs serait d'ailleurs un bel
honneur pour moi Fatou
si jamais elle est dispo comment je peux
laisser ma place volontiers à tous et
les discours pas de pression qui sait
pas le cas maintenant maintenant qu'on
est que Fatou en plus elle a pris un an
je pense qu'elle a pu l'excuse
de confiance et donc tu fais partie du
coup maintenant
on va voir si on peut faire un sondage
dans le chat aussi
en tout cas je vais vous laisser yes ça
marche bah merci beaucoup Samy en tout
cas de m'avoir assisté aujourd'hui parce
que sinon j'aurais été tout seul toute
la journée
et puis bah écoute à bientôt je sais pas
si tu restes stream toi je crois pas au
final du coup
si justement il y a des personnes qui
ont des petits problèmes je peux
toujours dépanner les remplacer au pied
levé
au plaisir sinon à tous et bonne fin de
stream bonne journée à tous
j'ai envie de partir moi aussi bonne
soirée à toi Samy et à bientôt du coup
je vais partir sur une
sur une
on va pas faire tout seul sur la MX cam
on va remettre la caméra numéro 6 du
coup
on va voir du coup Carson
ici
et du coup Fatou je ne rigolais pas
vraiment si tu veux passer c'est un
grand plaisir
ok du coup alors parti qui va durer un
peu longtemps celle-là est-ce que Prague
ça avance un petit peu il y a eu droit à
F5
tu as trop peur c'est Fatou ouais mais
avec moi ça va quoi je veux pas je vais
pas être méchant avec toi
ma la logique pour essayer de passer par
là mais d'un autre côté j'ai peur que le
roi passe là franchement c'est pas ça
hein franchement c'est final j'ai
presque envie que tu es noir quoi parce
que vous voyez je bouge pas vous voyez
je bouge pas
à cause du pion B4 et pendant ce temps
là il fait ça il fait ça il va ramener
l'endroit pousser le pion pas simple du
tout avec les Noirs en vrai
du coup
comment est-ce qu'on peut jouer ici
peut-être juste
que là ici c'est clair que les blancs
peuvent plus jouer pour gagner donc si
je fais B5 puis on prend non tu reprends
à 5 je pense puis on prend on te reprend
et peut-être un tour là il y aura
enfin d'abord ça ça va être nul je pense
c'est tranquille
avoir comment comment Prague joue mais
cette finale devrait être nul dans
quelques coups la légende qui ont
récupéré leur leur 50 minutes de rajout
de temps ils sont 41e coups ici
ok donc du coup de s'inquiéter jouer par
[Musique]
parram après H4 je pense à fois F5 aussi
c'est la même idée le cavalier va aller
où en F6 du coup ils sont cavalier de
faire C4
deux parties où
ça a l'air quand même complètement
terminé
alors du coup arroniaque F3 on est
toujours ici
donc qui est mort qui a encore beaucoup
de temps la pendule il y a eu un gros
rajout de temps et là il faut savoir ce
qu'on fait parce que si tu prends ici
puis on prend une finale avec un avec un
pion de moins pour
pour les noirs qui est faible et
difficile
j'ai trois pions qui vont avancer une
fois que j'aurais mangé les pions là-bas
et si il mange pas du coup en F3 et ben
écoutez
les blancs clairement le monopole ici
hein
il a fait nul tu es le premier finir
ouais finir aujourd'hui
il a fini notre saut parti
préparation intéressante une écossaise
où il a tout envoyé mais il a rien
obtenu et ça
ça ça a fait nul normalement quoi
correctement donc du coup celle-là aussi
de
Google ça va faire nul je pense assez
facilement
un cavalier prend ici celui de princesse
ça fait nul direct là on a plusieurs
parties qui vont faire nul très très
vite j'en vois je vois la Prague dirige
va goût cache rapporte ça fait un nul
très très vite
et je vois McDo slow contre est-ce qui
va qui va gagner très très vite donc
pour moi il reste que deux parties en
fait il reste Carlson Abdou et Ariane
Kemer c'est deux parties qui qui ont
vraiment un intérêt à suivre dans cette
ronde là je vais voir son petit truc ici
est ce qui est des résultats qui ont été
mis est-ce qu'on peut être un petit peu
un petit peu spoilé
tac tac tac tac
[Musique]
il y a pas eu de français
malheureusement on a deux Français qui
auraient pu être là on a une VL on a
fait Rosa mais malheureusement il y a un
problème il y a 2 ans avec leur gars et
ne veut plus participer pour l'instant
et
et mvl n'a pas été invité et de toute
façon mvl ne pas trop se tourner parce
que le format est un peu est un peu long
quoi quand tu joues 7 heures par jour
franchement
et du coup elle n'aime pas le format et
du coup il
même s'il avait l'invitation apparemment
ils sont pas allé c'est de gagner
comment vas-tu
donc du coup là il y a eu quand même les
prendre on va s'attendre à Tours
français 5 tours avec 4 et une belle
proposition de nulle ici
et les joueurs vont se quitter je pense
bons amis
il y a absolument rien à faire ici
pourquoi
qui se passe au Pays-Bas et que c'est le
numéro 2 des Pays-Bas numéro 1 est en
guéri
et ben ils invitent leur genre locaux ce
qui est je trouve assez normal
d'ailleurs avant de Forest il a gagné
l'événement il y a 2 ans
il y a deux ans avant de Forest il a
gagné au départage devant que diri
d'ailleurs c'était marrant deux joueurs
locaux qui s'affronter au départage en
blitz
et
[Musique]
donc en plus bon même si il n'était pas
il était pas hollandais je pense qu'il
mérite quand même au vu de ses résultats
donc
ça va on va quitter donc là il y a eu
chez Ariane pourquoi je prends un F3
maintenant ça va être très très dur pour
pour gamer qui a un pion de plus il y a
un pont et en plus net quoi genre
là je vois un cavalier peut-être
cavalier 5 qui va arriver oui ma
cavalier le cadre pour venir manger ici
sur cavaler prendre peut-être fou prend
ici à checker
je passe ça suffit mais
en tout cas il y a deux pions faibles
chez les noirs qui vont être attaqués
par haronyan
un petit fond en jeu 3 et parce que
notre pièce
je sais pas un des deux je pense
un des deux
j'ai oublié de Sami qui a pas raccroché
de l'appel je l'entends parler derrière
moi
je dois raccrocher moi-même il faut tout
faire incroyable
ça qui parlait en fond
alors du coup on est revenu heureusement
qu'il fait que de parler heureusement
aussi hein heureusement aussi il est pas
professionnel ça me non pas du tout
qui a grosse pression qui met grosse
pression et qui risque de gagner
la finale de carcène et du coup la
dernière partie indécisement c'est bon
il y a encore celle-là qu'il faut gagner
mais normalement c'est là je pense
qu'elle va elle va être gagnante malgré
ça qui a gagné après fouder 5 dame G5 on
gagne H4 abandon de vente forest donc
qui met du coup parram avec sa première
victoire dans ce championnat qui était
bien sûr bon ça faisait un moment qu'on
attendait cette victoire
donc on a aussi
Prague qui devrait faire nul ici ça ça
joue encore
nul aussi très bientôt aussi à Royan
gamers
du coup il s'est passé quoi
donc il joue un petit peu quand même
c'est pas possible à cause de d'un
produit
il y a pas d'échec pour qu'un scène donc
là il faut juste attendre
donc demain ça marche pas mal placé ici
parce que j'attaque là
et je suis quand même bien cette
centralisé ici il y a pas d'échec voir
comment faire pour prendre et c'est
peut-être gentiment regarde hop B6
rebelle
comme ça pas
parce que ça quand même pas mal de
contre jeux ici
et chance de nul et bien évidemment mais
c'est pas simple c'est pas encore fini
la finale qui peut encore être longue
très très longue
c'est dur parce que si le roi bouge ici
il y a échec
après l'échange de dames j'ai pion qui
court
c'est hyper dur même à calculer c'est un
cauchemar
c'est un cauchemar à défendre et
humainement c'est juste perdu hein bien
pour les Noirs c'est pas si simple
maintenant
faut pas trouver les coups pour moi
c'est pas si simple
bien sûr que ça risque de gagner
mais c'est pas si facile maintenant je
vois pas encore vraiment
comment est-ce qu'on peut terminer tout
ça
pour un perpète oui après le joueur vont
ils vont vérifier encore une fois Abdou
qui a les noirs qui jouent pour gagner a
quand même 42 minutes on a fondu je
pense pas qu'avec 42 minutes ils se
prennent un perpète
tu veux que je vienne ou pourra parler
bien sûr enfin tout moi je t'attends
si tu veux venir je t'invite je vais
venir je t'appelle après si tu veux pas
tu viens pas il y a pas de souci mais si
tu veux venir
je te je te mets dans la case à la place
de Samira
donc roi F2 allez incroyable les gars on
va on va assister à Fatou
par contre on a promis on la regarde pas
d'accord juste on l'appelle mais vous
mettez que le son s'il vous plaît mettez
un drap au dessus de sa caméra
je vais taper ça miraba par contre ah
non on va changer quand même je veux pas
laisser ça je ne peux pas laisser ça du
coup je t'appelle sur discord alors
où es-tu
ça va sonner à j'y crois pas Fatou qui
va nous faire le plaisir de venir
nous accompagner du coup sur tiascom
salut Fatou
allô oui non allô
non elle est pas là
et là ou pas
non elle est pas là elle nous fait une
blague
moi qui rêvais de parler de ça en plus
il y a eu ça
[Musique]
ça donne quoi les chéquier alors je peux
vous faire si vous voulez un petit
un petit regardez on va partir sur
hop les résultats rapidement donc là je
vous spoile un petit peu je vois en
direct que Google ça fait nul contre un
rapport
donc avec la finale qu'on que je vous
avais dit donc on a encore trois parties
on a qu'un seul contre Abdou on a pas
contre guillemets qui devrait faire nul
incessamment sous peu et on a un royal
contre gamer qui
joue encore et je pense qu'arrogène va
finir par gagner donc c'est trois
parties qui nous restent surtout deux je
dirais Carson et ronyan qui joue le
reste je pense que Prague et Aniche ça
va faire nulle de rapide donc voilà la
résultat pour le moment je repars sur ma
petite
un petit came voilà est-ce que Fatou et
de retour est-ce que tu es là
est-ce que tu es pas là bon s'il y a pas
de réponse je pense c'est qu'elle est
pas là je pense ça marche pas du tout je
pense qu'elle n'est pas là tu as un
problème de micro peut-être
il est bien par amour bien tu as vu il a
gagné en plus ça c'est propre il a fait
une belle partie aujourd'hui par un
une très belle par contre B5 je dis que
c'était un goût qui était qui était un
peu difficile
parce que j'avais peur un peu des
trucs comme ça mais c'est vrai que dame
c'est ça qui échec il y a pas d'échec en
fait pour les blancs après chaque croit
bouge du B4 et je pousse je pousse je
pousse et toi tu as pas d'échec avec tes
blancs
franchement je commence à penser que
peut-être qu'il va la perdre car c'est
hyper délicat à défendre
même si elle était nulle
en pratique pour Carlson c'est tellement
tellement dur
tellement dur à défendre
enfin tout je sais pas où elle est
mais je pense qu'il nous entend
ton micro est mort
un GMI de ma force de la force de abdos
en utilisant un pion de plus au final
mon 90 ok bon ça c'est c'est c'est mais
après si tu rate vraiment les les vrais
modules enfin oui c'est ça d'accord mais
tu regardes tu regardes bon moi j'ai
stocké -2 et quelques
mais en fait encore une fois c'est même
pas ça en fait qui est important c'est
la pratique en pratique pour les blancs
c'est hyper dur quoi
c'est hyper dur
en pratique c'est un cauchemar pour le
blanc
mais on voit qu'il a joué
une caméra dessus
pour voir
si
c'était quoi c'est la caméra c'était le
je vais essayer de voir
une caméra centrale non malheureusement
elle marche pas
je vais voir si elle marche comme ça
je pense qu'elle va marcher
il joue encore en fait
j'ai pas vous pouvez mettre maintenant
mais ça joue encore la caméra
caméra
Aronian qui joue aussi du coup il y a le
fouet F5 j'y pensais aussi pour changer
le mauvais fou du coup et fou à huit a
été joué
maintenant
j'ai peur de fou c'est un cauchemar il a
pris F6 étonnant
pourquoi il a pris
cavalier au 4 x 5
d'abord peut-être pour chaque
ça a du sens
par contre je trouve quand même ça
bizarre d'avoir donné le CASE noir
KUF à tout je crois qu'elle n'est pas là
je crois que tout elle a abandonné
le
va voir
du coup F4 c'est la partie c'est la
partie qui empêche faut 5 du coup menace
après Caval le cas tu as quand même fou